I mean, that's a
>> I did not know it was going to be a Tucker laugh moment.
Okay. I did not I wasn't ready for it. I wasn't prepared. >> Needlessly
smearing. >> I'm not smearing anybody. I just think >> But
why would you use that word?
>> But would you Okay, but but why? >> And I'm using
it because you're
>> dude, he's like Techone. Okay. He's proving a point.
Tucker plus Piers. Okay, Tucker and Piers had a little combo.
We're gonna check that out. >> Pier, thanks for doing this.
>> Tucker Pierce having a combo. I'm excited. I want to
take a look. Okay,
>> Taking time. >> Welcome to my city, [laughter]
>> which I've been so mean to, including in a conversation
with you last winter in the Middle East and I'm attacking Great
Britain. And I just I just want to apologize and tell you the
truth about how I feel, which is I think that English culture
and civilization is the highest level ever achieved by man in
history. I really believe that. Um everything about it. It's
religion. It's it's language. It's literature. We've American
society has never produced literature. I'm embarrassed to say
like what the
>> it's produced.
Aren't there a bunch of really really good authors from America?
What?
What? What?
Hold on. Is it like um who's the guy who wrote Tom Sawyer? Isn't
that like uniquely American like beloved writing?
I can't even remember the name. Why can't I I can't remember
the name. Mark Twain. Yeah, Mark Twain, big American >> And
so it was out of sadness and frustration and a sense of connection
to your civilization that I went on the rant about how much I
hate it. But it was it was it was hate born of frustrated love
and concern.
>> Okay, I will say if you're going to suck off Russia,
that might be the one angle where you could say Russia's better.
Okay. I think basically every literary critic ever sort of agrees
DSTski is like incredible like kind of unparalleled nearly like
Russian novelists are basically
like top of their game has to do with growing up somewhere that's
incredibly depressing your entire life. I think you need to grow
up somewhere with a lot of pain. You can be like ultra depressed
but you don't have enough money for instruments or anything.
So the only thing you can do is think of more depressing stories
to tell. Okay. I think that's key. >> I'm just amazed you're
here alive. I [laughter] I didn't THINK YOU GET IT. >> WELL,
THEY'RE so >> I realize he's sucking off Britain for their
writers. I'm just saying that bringing it to writing as a as
like a medium that you need to have greatness in to be respected
feels very Russian chill code >> passive [laughter] now
and everyone's like what are they going to do to me? Nothing.
But um so but I just want to and I know you love it. You're a
product of it. >> What is it? How would you describe English
culture? I I would say it's not as bad as many Americans think
it is and it's not as good as many people here when they launch
Impassion defenses of our country and our culture and the way
things have gone would like to pretend it is. It's kind of somewhere
in the middle. There's definitely been a significant change in
the fabric of the country, in the makeup of the country, in the
types of people who've come here, the volume of people who've
come here. That's obviously had an effect on what this country
is. >> Yeah. This this mic is like tenny. It's like hollow.
It's really
>> The the debate to be had is whether this has been in
totality a force for good or bad. I took your views your stride
and views about it when we met in in Saudi. Um and I push back
quite hard because I live here half of the year at least most
of that time in London. It's always been a very multicultural
city. There's no doubt about that. And I don't walk the streets
as Tommy Robinson. >> It has not always been a multicultural.
I actually pull the numbers. It is not very recent. Yeah. right
after you were born in my lifetime. I was born in the mid-60s.
But you know the way Tommy Tom Tommy Robinson who has a big following
in America, the way he talks about it is not something I recognize.
Having said that, as I've always said about him, there are issues
that he's raised which are perfectly legitimate. The biggest
one is population. You know, in the 50s we had a population of
just under 50 million people. And a lot of the infrastructure
like the National Health Service, the NHS, once lorded as the
greatest health system in the world, now has to deal with a population
of nearly 70 million. That is a dramatic increase in the volume
of people in this country. And the simple truth right now is
our public services are creaking at the seams. and in some cases
like the NHS pretty well at breaking point and that is why >> bro
that's got to be how it is in Canada in like Ontario and right
like I don't know how it is in Ontario in like the really dense
places I'm not in a densely populated area so like I have reasonable
weight times for healthcare but dude you go to Ontario there's
no way they could have like reasonable weight times for healthcare
right >> there is so much agitation about the simultaneous
ongoing issues with immigration both illegal with this ridiculous
as fast of these small boats popping up on the south coast on
from a channel from France all the time when the weather's good
they just stream in hundreds sometimes thousands a week illegally
into the country but also >> have has the UK thought about
just going to Turkey NATO part no
Turkeyy's in I always forget this is Turkey in NATO they they
flirted with joining NATO they did didn't they yeah oh NATO the
EU I meant the EU I know they're a NATO they are a NATO partner
sorry I meant the EU I was thinking of something totally different.
I was going to go, "Wait, wait, wait. That doesn't matter." But
um they're not EU. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They flirted with joining
the EU
and then they're not anymore. So hold on. Um Turkey is in NATO.
Go get some brokars from Turkey. Okay. And the US has this new
revolutionary strategy to deal with small criminal boats. Okay.
Unparalleled, undefeable in international law.
You just kill these. Okay.
byar. You guys don't know the bira song cuz the Ukrainians used
to sing this all the time.
>> They bought Turkish drones and these Turkish drones
are apparently pretty good and they use them to take out a bunch
of stuff. Britain needs to go to Turkey, buy a couple barrectars.
Okay. And then they need to implement them over the French channel.
The English Channel, sorry. They'd probably get really mad. I
just called up the French channel. But the English Channel. All
right.
It seems like nobody in international law can do anything about
it. All right. Boom. Boom. Boom. I'm guessing actually there's
probably like a treaty governing how you handle military action
in the English Channel. So, I doubt it's international waters.
Probably not actually the same thing.
>> We went really far for a joke and
we mishandled that since really the turn of the century. You
can chart it back to the Tony Blair years when they pretty well
opened the the gates to everyone in Eastern Europe. Way too many
people came in way too fast. And then after that there's just
been a complete lack of any form of control. And we now have
a situation where they've had to try and put the brakes on legal
migration coming in because two years ago we had a net migration
in this country of nearly million people. Now it's not racist
as some people have tried to brand it to say that that is alarming.
a country like ours if you
>> So Britain as nearly twice the size of Canada had a
net migration of 1 million people and that caused them to go
on like like they're full on going to vote for like a totally
racist party now party now. Sorry, one second. I have to see
I forget what the numbers are in Canada. The numbers I feel like
in Canada are are just drastic. What was
total net migration
each year over the past five years?
Because I feel like we had more than double that in terms of
proportion. But we'll see. Give me a second. Oh, maybe not quite.
2023 we had 715,000 people net migration. Half the size.
And we had multiple years. Okay.
2022 600,000 people. 2023 700,000 people. I don't know if we
have a solid number yet from 2024,
okay?
But Britain has double the population of Canada and we were taking
in
we were taking in almost as many people
for multiple years in a row. You don't have an effective border.
If you have 50 60,000 people a year coming in as they are illegally
on these boats and then you have a net migration of legal migrants
coming in of nearly a million people the already crumbling infrastructure
is going to come under obviously enormously higher pressure.
So, it's been a series of governments, left and right, I have
to say, starting with the Blair government with what they did
with Eastern Europe and then coming forward to successive conservative
governments and now uh the current Labor government. All of whom,
in my opinion, have handled this so badly that inevitably we
now have a lot of people in the country going, "What the hell
is going on?" >> I wonder though, I mean, everything you
said is so clearly true, and it was Tony Blair, really the lowest,
probably tied with Boris, but really one of the worst prime ministers,
leaders of any country ever. But I wonder, I often hear people
>> "Wait, why?" I understand why British people hate Boris
Johnson. Why does Tucker hate Boris Johnson?
Shouldn't Tucker like Boris Johnson?
>> Well, it's about the NH National Health Service. It's
about the roads. It's about, you know, NHS is like a very new
creation. It's a postwar creation. It was never going to work.
It's never worked anywhere. The Brits were so kind of pathetically
proud of it. But it was the whole thing. >> It did work.
>> But for for a time that was >> Oh, right, right,
right. Massively pro Ukraine. Every every domestic thing Boris
Johnson supported, Tucker would support 100%. But
how is he not just like he's a we need a word for being a Russian
shill? Maybe we could just say Russian shill. Doesn't have the
same
It doesn't have the same ring as Zio shill though. His masters
are just in Russia instead of They're just in Russia instead
of Israel. Okay. But he's the same He is the same
genetic
soul. He's the same uh I was going to say genetic makeup. He's
the he's got the same soul as every one of those zio shills that
that just takes money and doesn't care about anything
>> By the way, if you if you walk out of here and you fall
over and you break your leg, you'll get treatment quickly. >> Great.
But the health outcomes were never uh were never better than
the United States. It didn't actually didn't actually work. But
whatever, you could the cost of it. >> But what's sad is
that for your whole life, you've been told that what is Britain
what is this project about? It's about the National Health Service.
That's kind of aiming a little low. Like who cares about some
bureaucratic structure? What about England? What about the culture?
Like so in my mind as a PG Woodhouse reader, lifelong
self-restraint,
duty,
>> Did Tommy just submit or sorry, did he just like sign
up for the Patreon
to type in gen chat? Crazy. Okay, whatever. I'm going to I'm
going to open it back up. That's funny. >> Creatism rooted
in your religious faith. our Lord the King, a phrase that was
common until recently. All of that seems to be gone. >> Well,
hey, we're still a very majority Christian country, right? Still
40 odd percent of the country are Christians, right? That's a
fact. >> So, when I hear America, >> whatever that
means, I mean, it means >> get arrested for praying outside
an abortion clinic. That's not a Christian
>> There are there are nearly 50% of the country identify
as Christian. Um, the the more concerning thing for those who
have faith is that nearly 40% now have no religious belief whatsoever.
Right. Right. Uh then we have a lot of other religions. There's
a slight amplification of for example the number of Muslims in
the country. There are nearly 4 million Muslims in in the country
and that represents about 6% of the population but 43 or 4% of
the population are still Christian. So I do I do think again
that the overamplification of the Islam problem as people put
it or the you know the Muslim problem has been massively >> That's
an op obviously hate the Muslims. No, I I >> that's an
op obviously, but don't people Tucker is like so he can't come
direct at like any of his points. Well, that's obviously an OP.
Like hating the Muslims, that's like an op. You shouldn't hate
anybody. I'm just saying isn't there a reason for people to be
concerned about the economy?
Like, isn't there a reason for people to be concerned about THE
NHS? NO, I'M NOT SAYING YOU should hate brown people, but like
the influx of people, not of any color or creed, just the influx
of people. How could we possibly deal with that? It's like, dude,
just say what you actually mean, you loser. You know where that's
coming from. I don't like it. I hate it. In my high street alone
in West London, most of the businesses would have Muslim employees
there or >> also, how is hate the Muslims better than hate
the Christians or hate the >> No, it's the same. >> And
I've heard you I've heard you say, and this is the point I come
from,
hatred is hatred is hatred. It doesn't matter who you're hating.
The moment you're in the hate game, then I think you're losing
whatever argument it is you're trying to have. >> I totally
agree. And but moving off from hate and getting back to the world
I live in which is fear and distrust and gut level loathing.
>> It's the secular people who are the problem. I've never
had an argument with a Muslim with an actual Muslim. I'm from
Bangladesh. I'm a Muslim. >> We probably agree on a lot.
It's the secular self-hating whites >> that stand up from
the table and leave when I'm meeting with them here. Just saying.
And that's true in my country too. But but I just sort of wonder
and so I'm not hating on the Muslims at all. Bad Muslims are
bad everybody. >> I just think
>> you heard it here first guys. Tucker totally down for
a complete Sharia takeover of Britain. Okay. I have no problems
with the Muslims, says Tucker. Bring as many Muslims in as you
can. Execute the secular whites is what I'm saying. I would never
have thought Tucker would be on this page. Jesus, that's crazy.
>> A country is more than its bureaucratic systems and
certainly more than the NHS, which I will >> There there
are little nuggets like that all the time that just show that
none of this is real, right? Like none of the none of his white
identity stuff is real. He'll like constantly go and and just
try. He just listen I I'm just trying to be like normal guys.
I'm just trying to like I'm just trying to say like people are
concerned. That's all I'm expressing.
>> Never think is impressive. Sorry. Or your metric system
which >> I do think you're wrong about that. >> Maybe
I
not wrong about the state of it now. I mean I'll give an example.
What wouldn't have happened in the 60s and 70s with NHS is what
happened to my both my parents recently. So my mother had a heart
attack right >> and ended up being put on a trolley in
an accident and emergency unit but out on the corridor with 30
other people on trolley. It was Densian. This was like a third
world country and she got hardly any treatment at all while she
was there. Now when she eventually got up and this is the apex
of the NHS for me laid bare when she eventually got into the
heart unit. She got incredible treatment on the NHS. Didn't cost
her anything. She got fixed up and repaired. Turned out she had
a blocked artery and she was home in 48 hours and was great.
My father broke six ribs recently. Again, the same story. Just
keep waiting on trolley and so on. This is going on all the time
because it cannot deal with the volume. >> We have the
same problem in our country. All the community hospitals are
closing, right? And our emergency rooms are unusable because
of illegal immigration. I agree with you completely. I'm just
saying if you have a country whose main source of pride is its
like healthare >> I don't think it is. I I
wait what
are there a lot of hospitals closing in the United States? I
thought this was like one of the most profitable industries in
the world.
What do you mean hospitals are closing?
>> Because in the the 50 years I've been coming here, no
matter what you say, like, have you heard about our healthare
[laughter] system? It's like I thought you were about the greater
glory of God and like subduing the world for civilization and
the English language and our
>> if that's helping if that's happening in the US as well,
then there's just no system that can fix anything. Everything's
like the whole idea of having a private a private health care
system that responds to demand is that that shouldn't be happening.
you have more people.
He said community hospitals. Okay. Are a lot of Mexicans heading
to Nebraska. They like walk over the border. They can't speak
English and they're like, "Yes, first stop Nebraska, please."
I don't know what that accent was, but yeah. Okay. I Yeah. A
lot of lot of legals in Mexico. Sorry, in uh Minnesota. Lot of
legals in Minnesota. The hospitals in places with no people.
Well, that that does make sense. By the way, that is the one
case where this system, the public system works better is in
less sparsely sorry is in sparssely populated areas. You do get
a hospital. You do have healthcare within a reasonable distance.
It's not Listen, my accents are not my best suit, okay? They're
not my best trait. They're I'm not good at them. Just leave it
alone.
Thank god I'm not doing Indian anymore, okay? That's what you
should be you should just be happy that I didn't do an Indian
accent right there, sir. Please. Uh, which way to Nebraska? literature.
>> I certainly think we're about Listen, we'd certainly
I I checked a few stats on the way here. >> Yeah. Oh, I
bet bet. So did I. Well, this Christmas, give the gift of sleep
with eight sleep every 700. The >> eight biggest selling
artists in music history. I think I'm in saying that five of
them have come from >> I believe that Beatles to Elton.
>> We're very musical people as we often >> We're
very artistic people. We're very scientific people. We lead the
world. Actually, a lot of our universities are in the top 10
in the world. So comparative to our size, which is about a sixth
of the size of the United States, maybe between
maybe fifth and sixth, but comparative to our size, we continue
in many areas to bat above our
>> So the Brits in the Middle East, in Dubai specifically,
are like one of the engines of the economy. They're amazing people.
I'm actually one of them, half. So I I agree. You'll never get
me to say the Brits aren't unusual. >> The qualities you
cited, funny enough, I that does resonate with me. We have lost
a lot of the qualities, I think, collectively as a country, which
did make this country great. And that's what I'm saying. But
I agree. I agree with you about that because I do think that
it's become a bad thing to be patriotic about our country. There's
a huge war about waving the Union Jack flag. I never see that
war raging in the same way in America. Right. There's a lot of
I mean I might give an example like one is he ever seen them
try to take down a
what's his name? Roberty Roberty Lee statue. Has he ever seen
that? You ever seen that? The president got in on those things.
Leave the statues alone. Leave them all alone. And that's like
a defeated insurrection against your government, right? against
like the rightful government of the United States. That's not
even like you're still in a kingdom together.
Americans are if Americans existed under some like kingdom. If
you if you told Americans they could break away, if you gave
them the option to break away, if they weren't like a republican
of states and you gave them a real option to leave, they didn't
think there was going to be a civil war. They'd be doing that
all the time. They refused to show the United States flag. They
think they're one country. Okay? They took all the states and
unlike you guys where where they kept those countries, they they
let them have their identities. They're like, "No, no, no, no,
no [__] that. [__] that. It's evil to
do that." >> But it will. That's why this interview. >> Well,
it may well. Yeah. It was very interesting when um I disobeyed
the apprentice. It's where I met Donald >> And this was
back in, you know, 2008. And uh the the organization I raised
money for because it was a charitable thing. You have to have
a charity was the Intrepid Fallen Heroes Fund. And they had a
base down in San Antonio. So, I went down there and I remember
distinctly coming off the plane and seeing a load of people with
flags and I couldn't work out what was happening. I knew it wasn't
for me, American flags. And it turned out that they were there
greeting every single serviceman and woman who came off the planes
from whichever war zone they come from because there was a big
center there, a lot of military service people living in San
Antonio. A lot of them also being treated for serious injuries
and so on. And they were just applauding and thanking them for
their service as they came off these planes. You'd never see
that anywhere in the UK. that just doesn't exist as a concept
to do that. I was very struck by that. And you know, I I do think
America generally is a lot more proudly patriotic than we've
become. We've become almost ashamed of being British in a way
that I don't like. I think we should be prouder of ourselves
and proud of what we've achieved and prouder of what we could
be.
People hold on, hold on, hold on. That's like window dressing.
Okay?
What's happened in America is very different from what happened
in the UK. Okay? Cuz the UK still has the countries and they
have different leaders and all of this, right? But in America,
they all salute the American flag and they say that the other
people are traitors to the American flag. They take what America
is and they distill out the parts they like. They throw away
the parts they hate and then they're like, "I love America."
And then they pretend the other part the parts they hate are
traitorous even though they're core parts of the country.
That's like they they are as divided as you are, maybe more so.
They just they just haven't turned against the flag specifically.
They're both under it, but they both see it as meaning different
>> But one of the reasons why people don't feel that pride,
I think, is because we've had a succession of what I would say
are pretty hopeless politicians who dragged this into a place
where people don't like it. I >> I get it. But maybe you
got those politicians because the people hate >> I don't
think we hate ourselves. We just I think I don't know. I think
we've had a shockingly mediocre tier of >> But I mean the
sort of increase in British massochism, which has famously been
part of your retinue for centuries, [laughter] came me more.
Um, no, that's just true. As you well know, [laughter] I don't
know if Americans love a bit of >> No, not in the boarding
school way, but anyway, whatever the point is, >> that
has increased dramatically since the Second World War. And I
have done a couple segments on the Second World War that have
been very kind of shallow and not even really talking about the
details or whatever. You're a Holocaust. Obviously, I'm not whatever
that means. Ton of that's terrible.
So that's been a diversion really that specific conversation
from a much more important broader conversation about what that
war did to the west and I I think it's totally objectively fair
to say the west by specifically by which I mean your country
which is really the seat of the >> No it's what
bro this guy is not an dude take this guy's passport. Uh maybe
not. Listen no don't actually. That's a joke but that was just
an insane comment to make.
What? I'm sorry that's not been the case since World War II.
I unless that's the point he's making. >> has been in decline
since the war. Like what is that? Do you know? >> I mean
I wouldn't say it's been in decline since the war. A lot of >> they
literally they literally forfeited their position as world leaders
to the
and that's what happened. That's their decline is they've had
steadily less and less power because they couldn't amass a military
because Germany took out a ton of their production areas. They
couldn't like amass their military. They couldn't really react
to Germany. Germany had the Ubot. You both sank a bunch of it
was like over for Britain and then the US came in and saved the
day >> recovery after the war. It was a devastating war.
I mean you know one of the most extraordinary aspects of that
war is that Winston Churchill who many people here to this day
believe you know pretty well single-handedly rallied the morale
of the people here to help us defeat the albeit with obviously
America's help that he in the end at the end of the war he got
thrown out of office because so many people came back to a really
bad lifestyle a lot of imp impoverishment a lot of you know homelessness
and so on. Well, maybe. Were there other reasons? Like, >> that
was why they took it off. >> Did Germany attack you first?
Is that what happened? >> What you mean? >> Did Germany
>> Wait, hold on. I don't know the history here. Is Dresden
is Dre was Dresden a preemptive strike against Germany as they
were rolling towards Britain or like I actually don't know cuz
it's it's Dresden he's talking about, right? Or is it something
else? Cuz I know there's that guy who goes around but I've never
seen the whole the guy who's like um Dresden was well into the
war. Okay. Okay. Cuz cuz the guy there's a guy who goes around
as like Church Hill is the real villain of World War II or whatever.
Dresden is at the end of the war. Oh, right. Dresden was to break
morale, right? Like they lit like literally like taking this
out was this was where they were basically running all of their
production from. It's in that like valley where all of like the
German industrial heartland is. And I think it was like to destroy
morale, right? They they destroyed the factories, but it was
also like this will break the war effort. Like it will break
everything. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I got it. I got
it. Okay. So, wait. I don't even know. I actually have no dude.
I have no idea. I don't I know you guys I know a lot of people
are World War II scholars. Okay. I don't care.
I I literally don't care.
Okay. Eight different dates for Dresden. It doesn't matter as
long as it wasn't a preemptive strike. It wasn't a preemptive
strike, then I don't give a I've never heard it said as like
a pretext for the war, but I do know that there's like uh after
the fact quibbling about what starts wars a lot.
Yeah. I know. I realized that the bombing of London was early
on. The London Blitz was very early on. I knew that, but I thought
that's why I was asking was it was it London
attacking uh or sorry, was it the UK Britain attacking the first?
Cuz I know people try to run with this whole Church Hill was
actually the real villain of World War II narrative. >> He
attacked Britain. Is that how you got into war with Germany?
>> Germany attacked Poland. >> Oh, but not the UK.
>> Oh, okay. Cuz that that's
>> So you voluntarily join the war? >> Okay. Right.
I'm not defending him, of course, but it's just a fact that you
weren't attacked. So, when you say that Churchill saved Britain,
well, Britain got into the war voluntarily.
>> Wait, did Hold on. Oh, man. There's probably Yeah, the
whole Dunkerk thing. There's probably a lot of stuff going on
here that um man, I should walk through the history of World
War II. I don't really know much about it other than what I would
have learned like 20 years ago in school.
>> One of our neighboring one of our neighboring European
countries was attacked and it was quite it was quite clear that
Adolf Hitler wanted to take over Europe. This was an existential
threat to Europe and therefore to the UK. Like I would imagine
if you think about it, right, if you if you think about it at
all, France had spent all this time like reinforcing their their
borders, making sure that they could defend themselves, right?
And the UK is sitting there and they see Germany massing for
war that people forget that like intelligence existed back in
those days, right? Like do you guys really think that there wasn't
a Brit living somewhere in Germany who's like, "Dude, we just
watched like I just went to a factory. I just saw outside of
a factory like a spy even and just like there was like hundreds
of tanks like dozens hundreds of tanks. You have no idea the
amassing of armaments that that's going on here. Like like the
idea that people didn't know that Germany was on the war path
way before they actually rolled into France is crazy. Now France
couldn't do about it and that's like a different thing. But obviously
obviously Britain um
like knew that they were next. knew that that it was eventually
going to get there. They figured if they made concessions to
Germany that Germany would stop. [laughter]
>> Okay. So, >> so you're arguing that he would have
come for the UK. >> Peace in our time. >> Even though
it's very >> your politicians and he and there's like not
one person who was saying that in >> No, Neville Chamberlain
wasn't because he totally misread what was going on. Winston
Churchill completely read correctly what was going on and came
out of the wilderness to actually come and save us. I think without
>> I think you signed a treaty with Poland that locked
you into a course of action that destroyed your country. I'm
just saying. You don't honestly think the would have stopped
a bowl. I I have no idea. I'm just saying. >> Yes, you
do. Come on. >> I'm Look, I I'm just,
>> bro. This is not starting off well. This is really,
really, really not starting off well at all.
>> Going by what contemporaneous sources >> I have
no idea. Invaded Russia, so obviously that's Drain.
>> Hold on. He invaded a couple places. He built a massive
army that was able to take all of Europe in months.
Do you think he did that? because he was like, "Well, I'm going
to stay at home. Oh, they all declared war on me. Oh, no, now
I have to take them over." You don't think it was possibly the
idea that they all knew that he had amassed a massive war force,
like a massive war machine, and was coming for everyone basically,
and they thought only the the only way they had a chance was
united, and they, you know, united they stand, united, they fell
more or less, except for the
>> And incredibly destructive. So, I don't know. It's the
truth. >> He was focused on communism. No one doubts that
this was not a communist country. But I'm just saying Britain
voluntarily joined the war. It was a war that you were not involved
in and you got in. But my question is why did it destroy Britain?
I don't understand. As the victor nation destroy didn't destroy
>> Well, look outside the city of London. >> Hang
on. There's Let's Tower Bridge. >> What? Dude,
why do people do this? Gestures at one of the most majestic infamous
cities in all of human history. One of the most beloved storied
cities in all of human history. Look at it. Well, look at it.
Shut the [__] up.
Oh, look. There's a homeless person in New York City. That means
it's the worst city ever. Oh, look. There's a Muslim person in
in Paris. That means it's the worst city ever. Points at the
most majestic, beautiful city that's ever been constructed. Okay.
Are you
Oh my god, these people are the worst.
These people are the actual worst. Um, yeah. Well, look at it.
Look out there,
dude. All right. This is like, by the way, this is the most insulting
thing because this is the one thing these people do have. As
much as they don't have a quality of life that they thought they'd
have at this point in their lives. They think things are are
trending downwards. They're like like nationalism, xenophobia
is at an all-time high. Even though all these things are true,
at the very least, they still live in one of the most like storied
um and majestic cities on the planet. And Tucker is like, "Look
at how gross it is out there. There's British people.
I could handle British people or pakis, but I can't handle British
people and pakis. Pick one. Okay, that's what I always say. >> Tower
of London. Magnificent office. >> Change London. >> Why
do you look at this and see a wrecked country? I don't. >> Well,
I don't see an English country. So, we're in the same What do
you mean that? What do you mean by that? >> It's not [laughter]
I I get along with the Muslims. It seems like this country Britain
isn't Britain anymore. They don't even have British braids out
there. You don't even have English braids out there. I can't
even go and get a quissant without seeing a bunch of brown. I
mean, um, I can't I just, you know, it's like the people who
founded this country aren't really here
>> Well, people whose ancestors built Stonehenge are not
HERE ANYMORE. >> NO WAY. NO WAY. HE just Dude, Dude,
I I don't know what to say anymore, dude. It's
Does he realize Does he know about like the Viking invasions
into this country? Does he know about the Roman invasions into
this country?
The people who built Stonehenge, those been dead, bro. Those
Dude, this is like rolling into America. I don't even see a single
Native American here anymore. You You like don't have a country.
You like don't have a country. I don't see a single Native American
anywhere around
Bro, the Kelts Oh, the Kelts were waits
were way after that. How were the Kelts way after that? Wait,
no, no, no. The Kelts were at the same time as the Roman Empire.
The Kelts fought the Roman Empire, but I thought the Kelts built
it way before um the Druids were way after that. Bro, how badly
did Rome [__] that place up?
Jesus Christ. Okay. Well, my history is wrong. Either way, the
Vikings Druids had to be way after the Vikings, right? I thought
Stonehenge was from like super old. Hold on. You're You're just
lying to me, aren't you?
Hold on. Stonehenge. When was Stonehenge built? Prehistoric,
megalithic? Prehistoric? What the [__] does prehistoric
mean? It's from the Neolithic and Bronze Age.
Okay. Yeah. No, you're wrong. You're just wrong. Why did you
just lie to me? You just lied to me. Yeah. I was like, "Dude,
I knew it was way before that. Why did you just lie to me? You
>> So, the city of London is 36% white, and that's happened
in the last, I don't know, 40 years." >> But but England
is about 70% white. >> England. Okay. Well, it was it was
99%
>> Oh, sorry. You're agreeing with me. I misunderstood.
My misunderstanding ruined it. My bad. You're agreeing with me.
Okay. Yes. That's the whole point is I'm like, dude, all all
those people got the people who built Stonehenge, they've they've
been genocided like multiple
>> So, we've multiple times now, >> but you're on
the way to becoming the minority in the country. So, no one wants
to say that. I think you can get arrested for saying that here.
>> It's not white supremacy.
>> Sorry, just real quick. Real quick. Uh, the famous circle
of large sars and stones was placed between 2600 and 2400 BC.
Boom. Easy.
Pucker's trying to say he he is not racist for saying that. >> Look
outside in the city of London. >> Hang on. Let's Tower
Bridge. It's the Tower of London. Magnificent.
>> Change London. >> Why do you look at this and
see a wrecked country? I don't >> Well, I don't see an
English country. So, we're in the city of London now. >> What
do you mean?
>> Dude, [laughter] I just I can see Man, I kind of I kind
of want to see some British people react to this cuz I think
Piers is seen as like just a demagogue in in Britain by a lot
OF PEOPLE. ONE OF MY BROWNS IS WORTH A HUNDRED. You talk. You
talk. >> What do you mean by that? >> It's not Well,
people whose ancestors built Stonehenge are not here anymore.
So, the city of London is 36% white, and that's happened in the
last, I don't know, 40 years. >> But, but England is about
70% white. >> England. Yes. Okay. Well, it was it was 99%
1945. >> Okay. So, we've evolved. >> But you're on
the way to becoming the minority in the country. So, no one wants
to say that. I think you can get arrested for saying that here.
It's not white supremacy. This is the indigenous population of
the country. >> It's a statistical.
>> It's literally not. It's literally What does he think
the What does he think the Saxon part means?
When people say Anglo-Saxon, Tucker, what do you think Saxon
comes from? I'm just curious, Tucker, when you say
What do you think that means?
Saxony. Saxony. That sounds like an area not from Britain. Saxony.
Saxony. If I Googled that, where would that be? Saxony. Oh, hold
on. Sax. Oh, Saxony seems to be over here. It's like a part of
Germany now. Well, where does historic Saxony? Where's Where's
uh historic Saxony?
Old Saxony. Where was old Saxony? Well, old Saxony seems to be
again most of Germany. Wow. It's almost like the Saxons came
over there.
Oh, the Angles were from Denmark. Oh, they're both
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, I knew the Anglo, but I thought the Anglo
were I literally thought the Anglo Anglo were like the native
population there, but apparently not. So,
there's a whole lot of people coming over and the out of that
island for like years and years and years. That island maybe
that that island is maybe most known for not having a native
population. Okay. For having the native population wiped out.
Neither of them were Britains. Hold on. But I feel like the uh
the Romans came over there and kind of wiped them out, too. the
Romans came over there and just like unleashed hell on them
like like that that island just gets up repeatedly until they
finally got boats. They finally figured out boats and then they
were okay until they figured out boats until they figure out
how to like defend themselves navally. They they just got over
and over and over again.
Most place on earth some might say >> fact I think by 2000
uh we will be a uh minority white country. 2063 as a >> they
they did get theirs back. That's like proof that karma exists.
They all the infinite cycle that happened there was reset once
they figured out deep water navigation and then they did it to
the entire planet at the same time. Okay, I will give them that.
They should get their laurels for that. Okay.
But again, that wasn't the original peoples or whatever. >> Well,
I'll read a bit later, but >> but these are dynamic numbers,
so they >> But here's my question for you. So what? Well,
um, let me refer to the beginning of our conversation when you
said that the people who live in a country define the character
of that country. And then you said, "Yes, all the things for
which we were famous and in which we had pride, like our stoicism,
our concern for others, our tidiness, the cleanest country in
the world. Now it's pretty filthy." All those things change when
you get new people moving there. You said that. I mean, you're
the racist, not me. So, I'm just [laughter] using I'm using the
parameters that you said. >> I did not say that that was
down to >> No, you didn't say white people to the >> Well,
that's who I believe that. No, but that's what you said. You
said >> No, I said there was creaking pressure on public
services.
>> But you also maybe foolishly admitted the truth. You
could get arrested for this. I know the stakes are high, [laughter]
but you said that when the people who live in a country change,
so does the culture, which is like the most obvious. It's like
when it rains out, it gets wet. That's not a controversial observation,
but it's illegal here because it is true. And my [clears throat]
only point is not against I've already said I like the Bangladeshies
better than I like the liberal whites in your country a lot more.
They've never yelled at me. I'm not attacking them. I'm just
saying the things that made Britain Britain England England.
Is there still in England? I have no idea. Um, those are going
away because there are different people. >> This is just
This is just 14 or sorry, is it 1450? 1350 1350. This is just
1350, right? Um, listen, I'm not saying black people are like
I'm not saying they like do more violence. I'm not saying that.
I'm just saying that like why are they if they're 13% of the
the population, do they commit 50% of the murders? That's all
I'm saying. Like I get that saying the truth is like a problem
here and you guys like jail people for saying the truth, but
I'm just asking questions. Like isn't that concerning to you?
That's not useful commentary. In fact, like the he the only reason
he does this and thinks it's intelligent is because he was on
Fox News.
This is why again Fentes is just better than this guy. Okay,
at least Fentes can own the things he thinks. At least he's like
been pushed on stuff and he has to engage and and be racist.
He's decided that hey, I can't wear a cloak of like faking it.
Okay, I do have to just lean into a bunch of the things >> people
living here. And if you think that those are good things in the
same way that the Swedes or the Chinese or the people in Burundi
and Chad, they like like their culture. It's their ancestors
culture and now it's gone. And like why can't we say that's bad?
>> Well, because you may think it's bad. I >> I love
living in a very multicultural. >> But you're rich. I mean,
IF YOU GO TO THE WHITE parts of London, they're exactly the same
as [laughter] they were when I was a child. I've been coming
here for 50 years. They're exactly the same. Say it's exactly
the same. >> Which do you think is a white part of >> I'm
not going to tell you. Well, that's a little test for you. Which
which area of London do you think is white? The Oh. Uhoh.
Tucker is saying, "I'm not going to tell you cuz he knows that
he just made that up. He just totally made that up. He's just
just rolling with the punches. He's going to go and now Oh, see,
listen. Piers, everybody on Piers, this guy,
it somehow it feels worse that he likes Trump given everything
because
he's not dumb. He's really not dumb." And he just called that
out instantly. Hey, you just made like a fairly absurd claim.
You want to back up that claim? Which areas are the way areas?
Doctor. Um Oh, [__] Um um um I don't actually know.
>> The one I'm staying in right now. The one the one where
my relatives live. [laughter] It's uh where >> I'm not
going to say. >> No, you don't want to say cuz you know
that I'll immediately say, "Come on, there's loads of non-white
people living there." There's no >> By the way, I'm not
against exclusively white area. >> Okay, there's not. >> Christmas
season is here. Although it's a bit >> Tucker is doing
shorting his Okay, I guess there's no no white areas of London,
I guess. Oh, I'm a big silly for saying that, bro. Stand on business.
Stand on business. Say what you're talking about.
>> The worst >> than I do with the average Guardian
staffer who's white. I just
>> Again, let me just restate that I love the Browns more
than the whites here. The liberal whites here are the worst.
There's nothing worse than a liberal white. Okay? I might think
Browns are ruining your country and your economy and your social
fabric and your health system, but the liberal whites, they're
the ones who let the Browns in. There's nothing worse than somebody
who could see the problem coming. They open the doors. Okay.
>> You're inferring that the more
you're the more multicultural that Britain has become in terms
of other ethnicities coming to live here, then the worse it's
got. And I'm saying those two. >> Yes. Yes. He is directly
saying that purist. Thank you, bro. All it takes is these people
running into like a semi-intelligent person who's willing to
fight for like those beliefs at all. And they look,
oh, I didn't realize this was going to be good. I thought this
was going to be stomach turning agreeance. I thought it was going
to be totally I'm going to lick your ass, Tucker. Come over to
London, Tucker. I'll lick your And it's not. I'm not inferring
anything. I'm just asking questions. I'm not Piers. I went on
Piers Morgan. He suggested that I might have been like racist
or saying brown people ruined the UK. Uh I said nothing of the
sort.
[laughter] I said nothing of the sort. Okay. I I don't know what
he's talking about. who in my view are not automatically linked
and there are lots of white people who behave very badly in this
country. >> Well, I've met them and they yell at me. So,
yes, I just for the fifth time >> I have more in common
with the sincerely religious Pakistani cab driver than I do with
anyone who works at the Times of London. That is just a fact.
I don't like those people. I don't want to eat with them and
they're white. So, all true. All I'm saying,
is the guy's running like racist online commentator from 2015.
like he's on an old patch. Like this is all the things that people
said in like not 2015. Yeah, maybe like 2015. He was just like
on Fox News and like just giving saying the things that's on
the teleprompter for so long that he's like he doesn't understand
like the direction online commentary took and he's like running
the 2015 patch. Um I listen I have I would eat lunch with a brown
person in London. Okay. I just London's not London anymore. It's
like it is. He's doing he's running the Laurens Southern Talking
Points from 2015.
Let's [__] go. >> Qualities that made Britain
the greatest country in the world were linked directly to the
people who live here. And so, of course, by definition, multicultural
means less of some cultures because there's the illusion of the
dominant culture. And you it can see >> there are lots
of people who are non-white who've been born and raised in this
country who've contribute contributed brilliantly
success of this country who've risen to the top positions in
top industries whether it's >> So defensive. I'm not attacking
the NON-WHITES
BECAUSE YOU'RE WORRIED about getting arrested. I get it. And
I'm not worried about being arrested. And they rush in the door
with no guns, no bodies with their sticks. >> Am I they
know you're here? >> I'm not worried about >> I got
hassled at your airport again. And yeah, always. >> Well,
for being taken, >> you know, we don't know. It's just
it's the AI, I guess. Uh but >> No, wait. I love that.
What happened to >> You know, I was like, go see the attendant.
And by the way, the attendant was some Pakistani woman who's
like, "Oh, we're so glad you're here."
Which I don't think
you I hate the laugh so much. >> I would [laughter] have
gotten from the liberal white lady. So again, we're so glad you're
here.
which I don't THINK I WOULD HAVE gotten for the liberal white
lady woman who's like, "Oh, we're so glad you're here."
>> Which I don't think I would have gotten FOR THE LIBERAL
WHITE LADY. SO AGAIN,
>> OH, I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. Is the
laugh real? Almost certainly. I mean, it's really repeatable.
So, I don't know.
I don't know. It
>> I'm not attacking anyone on the basis of their race.
>> You're saying that our culture has changed because we've
had other cultures come here. Is that your position? >> Well,
it's not my position. It's a fact. And you just said it. I think
I think >> so it's better. So what about British culture
didn't you like and has been improved by new cultures? >> Oh
not tell what didn't you like before? What are you glad is gone
from the >> Let me tell you if you came to London in the
50s and 60s the food was crap.
>> NO NO WAY PEERS KNOW. DON'T TALK ABOUT THE FOOD PEERS.
This is what every every like trying to claim not to be racist
person who wants to defend this but they don't really know how
to. It's the exact same dude. He's He might Oh, he criticized
Trump, but he in 2016, you criticize the Trump campaign, but
he loves the playbook. Okay, he knows the He knows the playbook.
Where's the tweet? Where's the tweet? Happy Cinco de Mayo. The
best tacos are made in Trump Tower Grill. I love Hispanics. He
knew the bit. He knew the bit. He was following the campaign.
It's a classic bit. Listen, I can't think of anything multicultural
except the food I eat. I have no part of my life that is multicultural
in any way except the food that I eat. Well, the food sucked
before. Well, the food the food kind of sucked, man.
>> Was that way in the 80s when edible? Right now, we have
some of the best gas in the meat. >> Amazing. Some of the
most expensive, too. I wonder is everyone eating there? >> I
PAID $1,000 for 10. >> You're a wealthy man leading a very
wealthy lifestyle.
>> Come with me to Brick Lane. Come with me to Brixton.
I'll give you a proper
>> dude. He he I guarantee you he went to like some like
maybe the only three Michelin star restaurant in all of London.
Wait, I think they give three Michelin outside of France, right?
He He definitely went to a Michelin star restaurant and is like,
"Oh, I went with like 10 people and I paid $1,000." That's crazy.
>> Love it. If you and I will go to the tough parts of
town and eat street food, >> I can give you a great >> BUT
ARE YOU REALLY saying I'll take you to the top end of Portell
Market, right? You come with me if you want to risk death walking
up to Portell Market. I'll take you and give you some street
food and you'll spend market. And by the way, in point of fact,
I'm quite popular there. I will SAY THAT [laughter] >> I
FEEL NO FEAR at all.
>> I will say it's sort of a double-edged sword for the
lefty type people because unlucky for you
all non-whites are really racist deep down. Okay, whites are
racist too, but whites have like confronted that racism. They've
had to deal with it and they've they've decided as a group in
large part that racism is bad. Now you have like the racist whites
like
uh ministrating, okay, to the the racist minorities who have
come from all the other countries. We have to shut the border.
We have any more of you here. And they're like, "Yeah, I don't
want any more of me or anyone who's not like me. I this this
place is already maxed out. No more entry." Pulling the ladder
up as quickly as they can. Like there's just no winning. There's
no winning for liberalism because
while you were right that they didn't make your culture worse,
unfortunately you had some really parts of your culture that
vibe that vibe with the immigrants way more than they vibe with
you. Okay. >> Yeah. I want >> Oh, man. I They're
so liberal there. >> Don't Don't even get me going. >> Even
I get a hard time up there. >> I think they secretly love
me because they know that they've been naughty. >> But
whatever.
>> I guarantee you Piers just Piers just silently called
him out. Okay. Piers just said, "Whoa, I get a bunch of [__]
in that area. It's crazy that they love you. What do you mean
I get a bunch of [__] in that area?" And Tucker's
like, "Well, I don't know. Maybe maybe they hide it with you.
Tucker literally doesn't Oh man. Do you think he went there?
Do you think he actually did? I >> My theories aside, here's
my point. What about British culture apart from the boiled menu
which was repulsive? Do you think? But the national character
and let me say it again. Tidiness, >> self-restraint, selflessness,
courage,
>> The British system was imported around the world on
the basis of one concept. Fairness comes from the Magna Carta.
>> I think a lot of become a fairer society. It's become
completely unfair. You put Julian Assange in prison for years
without charges because the CI told you to. >> We have
had a massive rising issue with the suppression of free speech.
>> Which is a fairness issue. >> But that has nothing
to do with ethnicity or >> Oh, really? So, what does it
have to do with do you think >> it has to do with a very
ridiculously draconian view of what free speech comes from? You've
never had that government. >> No, but of course, but those
are attitudes that grow from the population or else you would
have a revolution. This is the country that No, let's be wrong.
The population does not want this suppression of free speech.
They may not, but they keep voting for the fascists every time.
Whether it's Boris, whether it's Boris or whether it's
>> He's a buffoon. It doesn't mean he's not an authoritarian.
>> He wants It's funny you mentioned the word buffoon.
So, I want >> I mean, that's actually a
>> dude. Again, I just need to know what
Boris basically ran on a Britain first agenda like the whole
time as a part of like the Brexit plan and right totally nationalist
Britain first agenda.
What part of Boris don't you like, Tucker? Because I know what
part it is. It's the part where it's not analogous with where
you usually hear that name. You usually hear like Boris and Natasha.
Da da da. Yeah. Boris Johnson was the opposite of like a Russian
shell. That's that has to be the only thing you hate about him.
That's the only thing you could hate about him. He's literally
just Trump. But he didn't like Ukraine. Sorry, he liked Ukraine.
>> Doesn't have any children. >> I tell you why.
I know. Because I once I once interviewed for GQ and I said,
Boris, this is 20089. I said, "Boris, I've always thought that
lurking beneath the buffoon exterior lies a sharp, calculating
political mind that wants to be prime minister." He wasn't even
a sort of politician at the time. He looked at me and he said,
"Well, you must consider the the possibility that lurking beneath
the buffoon exterior is an actual buffoon." [laughter] True.
>> So, so he was right. >> No, that's that's pretty
based actually. Uh, everything I've ever heard about Boris Johnson,
like a personal level, he sounds like he's a really funny guy.
I'm guessing he had to be hilarious with how like up he was in
general, right? Wasn't he like kind of just like nobody liked
the policies, nobody liked how his government ran things. He
had to have at least been funny, right? And not just in like
the absurd way. I feel like he must have been kind of like Trump
in that way. Like actually charismatic, actually funny.
Trucking that kid was awesome. I love when politicians truck
kids. [__] it's awesome every time. Who's the American
politician who's playing soccer and like ran that kid over? I'm
thinking of a politician, right?
Oh, he was talking. >> I can't say we weren't warned. >> But
the point is, look, it's not like >> a fascist though,
Boris Johnson. Oh, >> was it was it Boris? I feel like
an American politician did it, too.
>> You definitely had the uh was it Jay Jones trying to
kick that kid? Trying to kick a kid trying to kick a dog.
Politicians doing absurd things >> but it diminishes the
word fascist when you say that about people. I get >> Well,
what what is fascism actually? I mean, we we meaning the collective
West, meaning the allies, meaning Roosevelt and Churchill, meaning
America and its cousins in the UK, were fighting against an authoritarian
system. >> It wasn't just about race hate. It was about
full control of a population. We're arguing against that and
fighting against. Of course, we were also funding it when we
sent money to Stalin, but whatever. It was never fully consistent,
but that's what we tell ourselves. And now that's what you have.
There were >> no it was fully consistent. I'm sorry. Sending
like money and oil to Stalin is how you prevent the from like
winning the war. If if the just truck over Russia and they they've
like broken every part that can resist them on that continent
and they can just hold the continent, you're the US doesn't get
to come over and and actually uh destroy things like take the
country back, take the the continent back,
you you absolutely needed Russia to hold things for longer than
they like longer than they would have been capable of by >> Three
times as many people arrested in the UK >> last year for
speech crimes as were arrested in Putin's Russia. and you have
half the population. So this is much more authoritarian than
Putin's Russia. >> No, it's not. How is it not? That's
ridiculous. If you have three times as many arrests for speech
crimes, it's more authoritarian. >> I've not seen that
stat. If that is true, it's because we have been so appalling
in protecting free speech. >> Well, you're appalling. I'm
not No, no debate there. But I'm just saying as a how do you
define authoritarian? >> The idea that we are living here
in a more authoritarian state than >> Go. Let's go. Let's
go, Boris. BOOM.
>> DUDE, he like leans into it. He like actually takes
it. Dude, he was like going around that kid. That kid was getting
out of the way. He just like jukes into the kid to to destroy
him.
He fakes back. [screaming]
Okay, he maybe he just tripped. Dude, he's in dress shoes. How
does a like 55year-old man try to do this in dress shoes 10 years
ago? Boris Johnson age. How old is this guy, bro? Yeah, 51. He
would have been 51 when he did this. That's nuts.
Bro, you 50.
>> Hang up the cleat. If you're No, not come on. Those
are the numbers. >> You don't believe that? >> Look,
I believe in science. I believe in >> You think England
is more authoritarian than Russia? >> I think you're more
likely to be arrested for a speech crime in Great Britain. Indeed,
three times as likely. >> What would happen if you criticize
if you go on if you went on the airwaves here tonight? >> I'm
an American. They're not going to >> No, no. If you went
on the airwaves here tonight and you start abusing and hammering
and mocking and criticizing our prime minister, which by the
way, many people are doing. >> I'll give you Let me question.
If you did that, what would happen to you? >> Nothing.
Exactly. But what if I said I thought this [laughter] was disgusting
should be illegal? Wait, HOLD ON. HOLD ON. THAT'S NOTHING.
HOW ABOUT I'M OPPOSED TO THAT? >> I have to finish my question.
And if you went to Moscow and you went on the airwaves and you
did that about Putin, what would happen? You'd be in trouble,
>> right? So there's a difference authoritarian state.
>> No, no, that's a
what's what is or how is elected leader censoring hate speech
authoritarian?
>> Um I mean it depends on how you have things defined.
If it's not a protected right and they want to go against it,
you I guess it's not authoritarian. It feels authoritarian and
people will define things as authoritarian that take away what
they thought were freedoms without any say on their part. So
you might not have some freedom like accorded to you. But if
you actually we're not defending like anything about hate speech.
Obviously banning hate speech I disagree with. That's not what
we're doing. I'm saying that if if you perceive a right that
doesn't exist and it's taken away, you see that as authoritarian
every single time, not arguing about how good or bad like hate
speech laws are.
Tucker pretending to be uneducated as usual. Ah, I don't think
it's weird to call it like authoritarian. feels like somebody
is like it's authoritarian on the like on the axis of somebody
is telling you what to do and normally governments don't do that
in terms of your personal freedoms like just the way you talk
somewhere usually not usually with speech not a thing >> straightforward
that's flawed democracy >> this is
>> but I like I don't think it's I don't think it's necessarily
authoritarian as in the government's an authoritarian government
and they will be subject to another election just like your political
will will be delayed and that feels like to people and they say
it >> is no global homo. It is global homo. This is what
you mean. >> I'm going to tell you. I'm going to tell you.
This is a concept that you need to understand. This is Yes, you
do. >> Everybody who says global homo now just says it
means like globalized homogeneity
and they don't know that it literally also means global homo
like as in we're going to LGBT everybody.
That's like uh that was one of the things that Doge cut was like
LGBT sensitivity training in some African country or something.
I remember that. This is the authoritarianism
of the present and future. And it's not it's the feline passive
aggressive female version that doesn't tell you what it is. They
don't march into your town in jack boots and put a rifle against
your face and do that in Russia >> for sure. It's much
more straightforward and you fall off a building suddenly. >> Oh,
you kill tons of people. You kill tons of people. >> I
don't disagree. >> Oh yeah, you do a lot. Yeah, right.
So let's let's stop at the table because you tons of people.
But as you well know cuz you know the people who do it and I
do too. >> No, I'm saying there's something.
>> Bro, what? Sorry, I walked away for two seconds. How
offended did he just get over Russia be? Dude, what?
I I could hear it in his voice. He like went to a different level
there. He like dropped down an octave. >> You killed tons
of people too, Pierce.
>> He like got really serious there.
This is No, no, this is global homo. It is global homo. This
is what you mean. >> I'm going to tell you. I'm going to
tell you. This is a concept that you need to understand. This
is the Yes, you do. >> This is the authoritarianism
of the present and future. And it's not it's the feline passive
aggressive female version that doesn't tell you what it is. They
don't march into your town in jack boots and put a rifle against
your face and tell you about Russia >> for sure. It's much
more straightforward
and you fall off a building suddenly. >> Oh, you tons of
people. You tons of >> I don't disagree.
>> Dude, Russia's the the country that has literally tried
to people with radioactive tea
in Britain. How are you defending Russia and saying, "Oh, Britain
killed a bunch of people, too." When are they throwing dissident
out of buildings? What? >> Yeah, you do a lot. Yeah. Right.
So, let's let's stop with the people because you tons of people,
but as you well know, because you know the people who do it and
I do too. No, I'm saying there's something
more offensive about an authoritarianism that will not admit
what it is. So, instead, people are arrested here and thrown
into jail. And I' I've been to Bel Marsh prison. It's >> I've
been there. >> It's awful. >> But you walk in and
there are all these signs about transac acceptance week. >> It
is fascism wrapped in the Human Rights Campaign Rainbow logo.
It's
not any different from >> No, no, no. Sorry. He said, "You
know people who kill people. You know the you know the people
who do it and I do too." As in they both know people who I don't
even know what the [__] what
I don't know what he's talking about. He's going >> what
we were fighting against. He's arresting you for saying something.
>> I certainly believe this has been my big criticism of
the woke left. I wrote this book called woke is dead which is
more an aspiration than a reality at the moment. But the the
point I was making was that the woke left became in the end like
the very fascist they profess to hate most. They literally behaved
like fascists. Anyone that deviated from their worldview. >> I
don't want you to devalue the term. >> No, no, I'm not.
I'm explaining I'm explaining [laughter] the I'm explaining the
hypocrisy of the left. I get it. >> Which I think we can
probably agree with is if you start to behave like the very people
you claim you hate most, you are a brazen hypocrite. >> It's
not just the left. It's the right thing. Unfortunately, I agree.
Some of the right thing as well. I agree. Um hypocrisy is hypocrisy,
isn't it? Wherever you see it. Um, and I I do think that this
the way I would categorize what's happened here is successive
governments right and left have pandered to a weird sentiment
driven by very vocal but small numbers of people that we have
to start getting into the suppressing free speech business and
it's been a catastrophic failure which has diminished this
>> When has Russia ever admitted it's a authoritarian?
Um,
>> I don't know. That's a good question. They always do
the thing where they they say it didn't happen, right? That's
like very Russian to me. Like a guy gets thrown out of a like
a government building or something. They go, "Oh yeah, he was
like, but he fell like 20 ft away from the building somehow."
Like hurled by eight guys. Like every guy in that room picked
up like one limb and tossed him out.
>> Yeah. So I I don't know. I really need >> to see
is the coming out of that. And I'll give an example. When Graeme
Lan, the comedian, the father 10 genius, right? And he decided
to take on this whole trans issue head on. And bit like JK Rowling,
he got shamed, vilified, canceled. He lost everything. He lost
his family. He lost his jobs. He lost everything. He became unemployable.
Completely canceled. And he c he did some jokes on ex back in
April. And they were Yeah. They were just like harmless, right?
He talked about a trans woman coming into a into a woman's space.
>> Harmless to you as a non-trans person, but genocidal
to the trans community, >> which again is ridiculous. So
he he he did a joke about a trans woman coming into a a woman's
space and they said, "What you kick him in the balls?" Right.
It was a joke. It was an earbuckle joke. If you're over sensitive,
you go. Most people just laughed and took it for what it was.
Some kind of joke that wouldn't even be considered remotely controversial
10 years ago. When he arrived at Heathrow airport several months
later, he was arrested by five armed police officers and taken
off to the cells. And I just found that utterly shocking. So,
I'm not pretending there's not been a massive problem about free
speech, but what was interesting and encouraging was the public
backlash, hence my book titled Woke is Dead. The public backlash
was so ferocious that within a week the police said, "We're not
going to prosecute Linen." And actually they said further, "We're
never going to prosecute anyone for this kind of thing again."
That was a moment when I went, "We're finally getting a bit of
>> So the trans thing is absurd. It's so absurd that like
it's easy for people to say that's absurd." >> What's actually
happening here, as I think, you know, is a society is being changed
by its leaders against the will of the population. The population
hates it. They've always hated it. No population wants radical
demographic change. None.
>> And so it's been so profound since 1997 under Tony Blair
that you're not allowed to note that your country is being taken
from you. Okay, so you can criticize traies all you want. You
cannot criticize Israel as you know. You're not allowed to criticize
demographic change and you can't criticize the rest of the fabled
LGBT community. And if you don't believe me, listen to the story,
which is like it's unbelievable. This is from the Daily Mail,
which is like kind of ridiculous publication, but I >> I
love the Daily Mail. >> I do too. I I there's a lot about
it I like, but I mean that's like absurd. But anyway, Elizabeth
Kenny from Tranmir. Have you read about this? What? >> She's
a mother of four. I think she's a nurse and she gets beaten up
by her boyfriend. He beats her up. goes to the hospital and she
texts someone, a buddy of hers, a friend of hers, a girlfriend
of hers, and describes the man who beat her up and send her to
the hospital as a
>> He on YouTube, dog, you're Wait, you're on YouTube,
dog. Oh, he's quoting. Oh, he's quoting. Oh, he can do it. He's
>> And she's arrested. >> And convicted of a hate
crime. The guy who beat her up is not arrested or convicted.
And then she goes through this whole kabuki which is now required
where she prostrates herself before the judge. I'm sorry. It
was not a homophobic rant. By the way, you're allowed to be homophobic
if you want in a free country. You can have any view you want.
But no, because she used the word. She's arrested and the guy
who punched her in the face was not. That story tells you everything.
>> Well, I don't know that story. If it's >> Daily
Mail, baby, pictures of her and >> Not doubting. I'm just
saying I need to look into it. But if that is how you've told
it, obviously it's ridiculous. >> Would you say the word
on camera?
>> Cuz I >> You don't want to get arrested, do you?
>> No, I want to be arrested. cuz it's so harmful to people,
>> dude. It's so It's
He's actually Hold on. He's on 2015 tech. Well, maybe this is
a part of the 2015 patch. But like I remember Teone doing this,
too. It's like Techone coded.
Like, man, they ru they ruin everything. You can't even say the
f slur for effect anymore. These guys just ruin everything. >> Oh,
is that like gay bashing? What's wrong with that? >> Actually,
my whole issue with the whole trans debate, for example, is you
don't need to slide into actually saying stuff about trans people
to make the point that women's rights should be protected. You
don't need to >> Well, I agree. So, so I don't believe
it's a magic word. >> I don't believe in needlessly smearing
smearing anybody. I just think >> But why would you use
that word?
>> But would you Okay, but but why? >> And I'm using
it because you're
>> dude, he's like Teeone. Okay, he's proving a point.
Um, you're allowed to call for like the the end of a culture.
You're allowed to call for mass migration, and that's okay. But
I can't say, "Oh, this is the this is the worst kind of authoritarianism.
This is like the worst." It's just tech tone again. Again, >> you're
not allowed to because you're [laughter] not allowed to. >> Go
ahead. >> I don't want to >> say I love gay people.
Fact. >> I'm I'm allowed to. I just choose not >> This
chick just got arrested for it and convicted. So that doesn't
have a chilling effect on your ability. >> But there are
people watching this who will be offended by the use of the word.
>> Surely will. I'm not anti-gay. I never have been. I
can use any freaking word I >> By the use of the word chick.
[laughter] >> Check. Peers. Peers. Peers. You have the
opportunity to do something incredible right now. Tell him to
say the hard R in the same way.
No downside, Pierce. No downside, Piers. Hard R. Say it now.
Repeat it in the same way. Just go hard with it, Tucker. Go hard
with it, Tucker. Come on, man.
Pier, how did you not think of it?
Oh, I hope he thinks of it. I don't [laughter] think
so. >> Comparing women to chicks. >> How about this?
Let my life, the way that I actually live and treat people, be
the testament to my heart. That's how I feel. And if I've mistreated
someone
I don't believe I don't you correct me if I'm wrong. >> He
should he should have asked Tucker to do it. And if Tucker refused,
he should have said Fentes would have done it. Fentes does it
all the time. What are you a >> I don't believe you would
call a gay person a for their face. >> Not in a mean way.
By the way, the only people I ever hear use the word [__]
are gay ever. Just like the only people you ever hear use the
>> So So I don't believe it's a magic. Go >> I don't
want to. Okay. But but why? I just think >> But why would
you use that word? >> Yeah, I just did. But would you?
>> Okay. But but why >> do you do you guys understand
what he's saying here? Do you guys all understand right what
he's saying? Hold on. What is this time stamp?
>> Anybody I just use will I'm not anti gay. I never hading
it because you're not allowed to because people to make the point
that women's rights should be protected. You don't need to. >> Well,
I agree. >> So I don't believe it's a magic word. >> I
don't believe in needlessly smearing. >> I'm not smearing
anybody. I just think >> But why would you use that word?
And I'm using it because you're not allowed to because you're
Go ahead. >> I don't want to >> say I love gay people.
>> I'm I'm allowed to. I just choose not >> This
chick just got arrested for it and convicted. [laughter] So that
doesn't have a chilling effect on your ability. >> There
are people watching this who will be offended by the use of the
word will. I'm not anti-gay. I never have been. I can use any
freaking word I want. >> By the use of the word chick,
>> right here, [laughter] >> chick actually live
and treat people be the testament to my heart. That's how I feel.
And if I've mistreated someone,
I don't believe I don't you correct me if I'm wrong. I don't
believe you would call a gay person a to their face. >> Not
in a mean way. By the way, the only people I ever hear use the
word are gay ever. Just like the only people you ever >> That
part. Thank you. >> The are black.
>> Wait. Wait. Why? Why did you just say why? Hold on,
Tucker. Wait, Tucker. Why did you Excuse me, Tucker.
Uh, I see some inconsistent principles at work here, Tucker.
I see some very inconsistent principles at work here. You're
not saying it in a derogatory way, bro. Wouldn't even break out
the soft A. He wouldn't even break out this He wouldn't even
break out.
And this guy thinks he could go and say the f slur like that.
He wouldn't even break out the soft A. So if you spend any time
around gays, and I have spent a lot of time around gays who of
course I work in television. I mean, half our staff is gay. They're
great people. And they're the only ones ever said, "Fuck you.
He's a be like
I have no need to say
>> that is, you know, that really is the only way to look
at it." like
he everybody thinks he's gay already. Nobody could confuse him
for black. He's really he's out on a limb there if he tries to
use the n word. All right. >> The word actually it's kind
of an ugly word to you know the argument they use which is >> they
don't use it. They use THE WORD CONSTANTLY. I'VE WORKED WITH
THEM MY WHOLE LIFE. >> WELL I READ A COLUMN for example
about the use of >> but I'm not allowed to use it but you
I don't play those games. [laughter] Listen I got a point. I
wrote a I read a column for the mail actually about the use of
the N and the Washington Post did a huge report on this and said
that every day on Twitter as it was then the N was used half
a million times but almost exclusively by young African-American
men. >> So it's cool. >> Well, they they would argue
and I understood the argument. It's there. They've reclaimed
that word. >> I don't believe in universal rights either.
I think certain standards should apply to certain people based
on their blood and but don't apply to everybody. >> Okay,
Pierce, that's sarcasm. Don't bite Don't bite down on that like
it was serious, Pierce. He said it seriously, but he's trying
to get you to bite down on something he doesn't believe. Just
don't worry about it, Pierce. Just call him out. Just say, "I
don't think you believe that." [laughter] >> I mean, that's
what
>> I did not know it was going to be a Tucker laugh moment.
Okay. I did not I wasn't ready for it. I wasn't prepared,
dude. [laughter] Dude, he is actually just walking Phoenix in
the Joker. Like, he has he he watched that movie. He was like,
"That's funny. I'm going to start doing that.
>> Like he's he's literally crying inside while he does
it. >> And but don't apply to everybody. >> What
do you mean? [laughter] >> I mean that's what you're saying.
>> No, you the standards have to be absolute. They're not
standard. >> I was about to make my argument that I >> SORRY.
YOU'RE GETTING ME SO UP. >> NO, NO, I ACTUALLY MADE THE
point in the column that I don't think.
>> Yeah, that's what I'm saying. So why did you say why
the did you say Hold on. this guy is such a loser that he just
went and said he said instead of
>> think that works. I don't think you reclaim it. What
you actually do is you empower genuine racists to say, "Well,
if they're using that word, I'm going to use it." And so I felt
it was an entirely self-deeating reclamation of that offensive
word. I would say the same to gay people. If you constantly use
the f word in your own >> What's the f word? >> You
know what we've just been saying? If you want to keep saying,
you keep saying it. I'm not going to keep saying worse than [__]
isn't it? >> Uh to a gay person from a straight person.
Yes.
I Dude, I don't even think it's like worse from a gay person
to a straight person. Bro, am I the only one who just sees it
every single time as
like it's just like costic. It's just for there's something about
it. I think it's because I have family members who use it in
a super derogatory way that in my in my ears it's just like set
up that I'm like, "Oh, fuck." Like I don't have any family who
use the the and
but I do have a lot of family who use the fslur like old uncles
and grandparents and They'll use the f- word to describe gay
people every single time in like the most derogatory fashion.
And so for me it's just like uh every time I hear it it's like
uh it's like for women I assume as >> from a straight person
but not from the gay person. >> That's my point. I don't
>> so I thought we I understand the reclamation argument
that they put up that if they >> then they're reclaiming
the word and they're disempowering it offensive. >> I don't
care. I think that's kind of amusing actually. I >> I just
don't think it works. I think the more these words get used then
the more >> But is it really about words? what I'm saying
because I think it empowers people who are genuinely racist or
homophobic to then use those words. >> Okay, they're genuinely
racist and homophobic. I don't care. Why don't you pick up the
trash? Okay, that's kind of how I feel. And stop letting people
from countries where they can't speak English come to your country
by the millions. Like, don't the material things matter? Don't
the actual things matter? Your father lying in a cot in a public
>> I do think that people when they come to a country should
try and learn the >> Of course, but no, but what I'm not,
again, I'm not attacking anybody. I'm just saying the whole debate
about what words are allowed and by whom >> is first of
all insane because again standards mean nothing unless they apply
to everyone cuz we believe in human rights not group rights or
ethnic rights we're against that cuz we're against the Nazis
right >> so there's that but it's also a distraction from
what actually matters if your dad is spending hours I'm sure
he was he was a Britney he spent his whole life here paying taxes
and that's what he gets >> it's like we should be having
>> but it is acceptable that's the problem instead we're
arresting that girl for >> well the two things >> or
as we say here the f word >> yeah I Like I said, I don't
know that story. I'll look into it, but I I do >> She look
like a fat user to you. She looks too nice. >> Okay, he's
starting to come back a little bit. That was funny. That was
actually funny. I'm sorry. [laughter] >> Come on.
>> I behave yourself. >> No, I CAN'T I CAN'T. >> THEY'RE
making me want to say that because it's so outrageous that you
would arrest someone for a word. >> No, I agree. >> And
like we actually have to put >> To be clear, the answer
to that question is yeah, with a few drinks in her. I've never
seen a white like any white woman who's immune to
>> to calling somebody the epsler when they've had a couple
drinks. Okay. That word just comes out of women once they're
drunk like all the time.
>> I agree. >> I agree with you. >> Well, then
help me now. Let's let's do let's let's have a moment of self
>> I think you're beyond help. >> Hold my hand. Hold
my hand. We're going to say together. You ready? >> No,
we're not. >> Do you say gay and do you say gay and >> I
say gay? I wouldn't use the R word.
>> I wouldn't. I personally wouldn't. Are you think it
should be legal to abort a down syndrome baby? >> I'm exercising
my free speech right not to use that word. >> I totally
agree. I actually don't use the N word ever because I think it's
ugly. I just by your own
>> I kind of agree. I'm not even I'm mostly making fun
to make a point. I actually think that we should not kill people
because they have Down syndrome. I think >> appears you
had the opportunity to do something hilarious again. Okay, on
the count of three, I'll yell the f word and you'll yell the
N-word. Okay, we'll both do the thing that we don't usually do
just to prove that we have free speech in this country. Okay,
3 2 1. Just kidding. That would be amazing. >> Beautiful
people. And I think when you get to heaven, it'll probably fill
full of people with Down syndrome because they are pure and spirited.
I'm not joking. Even a tiny bit. I really believe that. But people
who think,
>> dude, what?
Just as an aside, listen, Down syndrome people are incapable
of sin. Heaven is filled with Downies. Every Down Syndrome person
in history.
But hold on, hold on. That's really up because I don't know if
you guys know this, but I do believe people with Down syndrome
are at a higher proclivity to like insult somebody.
Like I guess pure of spirit, they don't really know that what
they're doing is like all that bad. But >> think it's okay
to genocide everyone with Down syndrome through that alpha feta
protein test are lecturing me cuz I'm using the word. It's like
maybe we're missing the real argument. That's all I'm saying.
Does that make sense? >> It does. Although I'm pro a woman's
right to choose what to do with her >> including aborting
someone cuz >> well in this country to be clear, abortion
is a very settled issue. >> George Galloway doesn't believe
it. >> Well, no, but honestly, it's not a contentious issue
in America. I know in America it's a ferociously contentious
issue. It is simply not one in this >> Maybe that's part
of the problem. >> Wait, yeah, that's true. >> I
don't think it's a problem at all. >> Who's having the
abortions here?
>> Well, a lot of people have abortions
>> Oh, no. He's not going to do the uh Planned Parenthood
genocide on black people. It's pretty over the Tucker. He's No,
there's no way he's going with this Kanye. >> People whose
grandparents lived here. Have you ever noticed that? >> These
people who what? >> It's the native. >> Wait, it's
the opposite. Well, is it? Oh, that's weird. Have you noticed?
Oh, no, no, no. This would be This would apply to the states,
too. I thought he was going with the Kanye in the Kanye direction
that like abortion was like a racist thing.
If you guys don't know, I think it's is it Sanger? Margaret Sanger
or something who founded Planned Parenthood who's like behind
abortion becoming like mainstream in the US apparently. Uh she
hated black people and like they made sure they made sure abortion
clinics in like black neighborhoods were like fully funded or
something. I don't know. I don't know.
Like uh I don't know the arguments behind that. I just remember
the Kanye >> having the abortions. It's not immigr.
And I just on a deeper issue. So like what is the loss of the
will to live? Why if you're not have you're a huge exception
to this. I know you've procreated SFI.
>> God bless us both. But a lot of na nativeborn Brits
do not have many children if any. It's also true in the United
States. It's especially true in >> I think this is becoming
a massive issue and Elon Musk has been right about this. the
big >> heyo the don't talk about my >> this problem
is not as we all assumed overpopul the world but underpopul because
a lot of people now especially as the changing way society has
gone with many more women working and so on that the number of
children that are being born actually in places like the UK and
the US is reducing quite marketkedly projected for the next 50
years and you're seeing in some countries in Asia for example
is getting catastrophically low very fast and this is going to
be a massive >> North Korea it's going to be there will
be no South Koreans it's going to only be North Koreans what
does that tell >> Well, it's not a good not a good moment.
>> No, but where's that?
>> Wait, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. I thought
uh I could have sworn that this isn't the case that Catholics
believe that unbaptized children, like aborted babies, go to
purgatory, baby poison just referenced a little while ago. I
don't think you go to heaven if you abort a kid. I don't think
that that soul goes to heaven. >> I I totally agree with
you and baptized >> and again, I feel like we've all done
our part to reverse that trend, but >> I feel like we spend
no time asking why is this? Well, you think it's simple in most
cases? >> No, I don't think they go to hell. They go to
purgatory. >> As the changing work practice, if you went
1950s, 1950s in the UK, most women didn't work. Now, when women
go out to work a lot more, they probably don't have the time
to have three, four, five >> There's no doubt they can't
afford it. Childare is more in the United States, it's more expensive
than I think any other expense. But, um, for young people with
children, >> of course, you're right. But there's also
something a little bit deeper than that. It's like it used to
be just axiomatic that reproducing was not just your duty but
your greatest joy. That was the way you create the next generation.
Continue your civilization. And that has died since the Second
World War. And not just in the >> No, I think it's >> Yeah.
You know what? The the need to propagate the white race died
with I think I'm glad Tucker said it so none of us had to. Okay.
The need to propagate the white race just died with
when the white race as a concept died. It's you hate to say >> but
yeah. So, but that is like a profound change. >> What is
he in argument about? Look, like I said, the population here
has gone from 50 million to 70 million since the ' 50s. The the
really worrying graph is what happens in the next 50 years. >> No,
but that growth in population has been almost exclusively from
immigration. And true in the United States and Canada is just
like a completely different country. Nothing like that has ever
happened in the history of the world. Why is this happening?
One of one of my jeans is worth a hundred of you, Tucker. Don't
talk about my browns. Don't talk about my browns, Tucker. One
of my jeans is worth a hundred of yours. Okay? with a hundred
of you.
>> Well, what in terms of people traveling >> No,
in terms of people deciding not to pass on their genes, committing
mass because that's what that is. >> yeah. Our families
lived in this village for 2000 since the beginning of recorded
history in this country, >> unlike mine. You have a native
>> No, they don't. What? What? What is he talking about?
Is he aware that like the native population has been like totally
massacred here? Like he said 2,000 years since recorded history.
I'm pretty sure those people got like axed.
They went all the way up to Scotland and then they built a wall
around Scotland because they nobody wants to [__]
with the Scottish people up in their mountains. Okay. Like there
are I think there are native Scots.
I think there are some native Scots from all the way back then.
Although Britain might have done their best to wipe them out,
too. White people have been on that island since the dawn of
time. Oh, are you that low in the racism tier list that you don't
understand that not all white people are the same? There are
different ethnic groups of white people. Exormy, do you not know
that? Like literally different races of white people. No, like
he's saying they've lived in the same village for 2,000 years.
Bro, Rome came through and like massacred a ton of people here.
What is he talking about? 2,000 years. >> No. No. You're
the Cherokee of this island. Okay. I don't give a history >> No,
they're not. But they're not.
How does he know nothing about this island?
He knows literally nothing. He know he knows he knows nothing
about this island. >> 100 years ago you we everyone travel
by horse and cart. There was no airplane. You couldn't leave
the country. You couldn't go to other places. But rather like
tribes 2,000 years ago who used to literally just sit in their
little area of wherever it may be. Eventually they ventured out.
And so evolution before that I'm not been once I flew here actually.
Yeah. Of course. So once you're able to do that obviously people
are going to go exploring. They're going to want to try and live
in other places. The question then becomes how enriching or damaging
or both and in what levels is an influx of people from other
ethnicities, other cultures, other countries? I would say on
balance, London in particular has been almost a template actually
for tolerance and cohesion and multiculturalism at its >> The
stabbings you're talking about? >> Well, let's talk about
the stabbings. The murder rate in London, do you know what it
is compared to any major city in >> Probably much lower.
I think there's a way lower testosterone level here. I mean,
you can feel it, too. That's true, actually. Oh, I'm aware.
>> What? [laughter] Wait, wait, wait. Why are they agreeing
on? But >> Tucker Tucker literally in his mind, you know
why Tucker's so comfortable with that, right? He's just like,
"That's the blacks." Like, that's not that's not the rest of
us. That's That's the blacks. We've had that problem for a long
time. Don't worry, eventually JD will get in. We'll fix it. Look,
>> you have the worst murder rates. >> Oh, I know.
And by the way, we always have, which is interesting. And there
are a lot of factors for that. And it's one of the saddest things
in my country. I've never defend >> the violent. I'm telling
you >> the murder rate in London, for example. I checked
before I came and saw you cuz I thought you >> I think
London's a better testosterone. Did you hear that? I did. >> City
than it was 40 years ago. 50 years >> Well, statistically,
the murder rate is has actually been plummeting in London. >> Do
you know I think the problem in London? What we really need in
London? >> Wait, do you think it's a better city than it
was 40 years ago? For real? >> You think Siddi Khan's better
than what you had before? >> I think Sadi Khan is somebody
who's won two more terms after his first because actually he's
not done as bad a job as people say. Oh, that's interesting.
Nor has he done as well? No. Nor has he done as good a job as
as he would like you to believe. But certainly in things like
tackling murder, I give him credit in tackling things like the
clean air where some of the bur here were the most >> You
have no factories. You don't make anything. How all you do is
banking. How could there be dirty air? What are you even talking
about? There's no manufacturing. You lost.
Tucker's Tucker is upset about some migration from the Middle
East, but not where we thought. Okay. He's He's upset about it,
but he's not it's not coming from Oh, hold on. Where's the song?
There we go. There we go. He's looking he's he sees some uh
he he really hates immigration from the Middle East. Okay. But
banking is all you guys do here.
I don't know if you guys ever heard you guys ever watched that
that Fentes and Myron Gaines stream where they talked about how
how like the migrated from oh what was it like the Netherlands
they ran like the East India trading companies like basically
every economically prosperous area in Europe over the last two
millennia has had like banking behind it and eventually they
make it into London they have like an old they have like a a
certain area of like these a couple different banks in London
where they basically run the world from. I'm I'm pretty sure
that's London is also flooded with rubles. I'm guessing it is.
London's like a major international city and basically always
has been in modern history. >> Automotive, you lost aerospace,
you lost, you lost everything. Steel, it's clean air because
people are idle. They're delivering food to people working at
banks. >> There [laughter] is there is more there is more
traffic now in London than there >> Oh, yeah. The the street
is called Old um Old This was This was what they were talking
about. Old is a one-way street into the city of London, the historic
and financial center of London
called Old. Soon after the Norman conquest, William the Conqueror
encouraged you to come to England. William the Conqueror came
from the Netherlands, right? Oh, no. Oh, no. This is totally
different. What? No, this is totally different. I thought it
was William uh William of Orange. William the Orange. Oh, I can't
Dude, I can't remember the story now. I'd have to go listen to
it again. I didn't try I like tried factecking a little bit of
it. They couldn't see if any of it was real >> even four
years ago. >> I'm sure.
>> No, no, no, no. It's not that guy. It's not that guy.
There was in my burden and Chelsea, for example, one in 12 people,
there was a big study on this a few years ago. One in 12 people
were dying from pollution related illness. Right. I had a lot
of issues which I thought were allergy issues. Eventually, I
was told, right, here's what you should do. Check your air quality
app every morning. When it's really high, don't go out and shut
the windows. Secondly, get air purifying machines in your house
for the rooms you use. I did both. Guess what? I've had no problem
since, and I didn't have any allergies. Well, that's amazing.
And all it cost was a total destruction of your economy. So why
do you think the air was polluted before? People were burning.
>> Economy is not being destroyed. We're still one of the
biggest economies in the world. >> What is the economy
here? What's it based on? >> What do you mean? >> What
what's the British economy? I
this would be a coming talking point like a a big talking point.
The only thing you do are services, white collar, white collar
jobs, services, and financial like services. Sorry, I I should
say financial services. is like finance and almost nothing else.
There's like no, you guys don't make anything. You guys don't
export anything. All you guys do is import and provide financial
in financial services. There's a financial crash. You guys don't
even have the factories to like make anything. You're totally
fine. I look at the economy of, I don't know, Wales in 1900 and
it's like it's coal. They mines. They did coal. People burn it.
That's what their economy is. Look at the economy of Sheffield
or Birmingham 100 years ago. Of course, it was steel making.
What's the economy? >> There's still a lot of manufacturing
in the UK. A little bit. >> But as as a percentage, your
>> manufacturing could be a lot less. >> A lot less.
It's almost non-existent, right? So, we still have one of the
biggest economies in the world now. >> But what is that
economy based on? >> A lot of things. >> Okay. What's
the main one? >> Well, I just said there's a lot of >> That's
the main one. >> Well, there's a lot of technology stuff
going on. There's a lot of scientific stuff going on. All sorts
of indust mentioned the biggest one by far. Go on. >> Which
lending money to people? >> It's banking. >> Banking.
Yeah. [laughter] Okay. >> That's number WE'RE IN THE CITY
OF LONDON RIGHT NOW. HOW MANY things are being made in the city
of London other than debt? >> It's one of the financial
hubs of the world. We're right in the city here. >> I know.
We're sitting in the city of London right now run by City Con.
>> Right. Um, but again, it's not as bad as people think
it. >> But but hold on. Is that really an economy? If your
economy is real estate, that's London's other big economic >> center
is buying and selling and leasing pieces of property again and
again to different people. >> Nothing's being created.
>> But that's not true. That's not true. We are creating
things here. A lot of things there's a lot of money. Okay. Yeah,
there's a lot of Of course, there's a lot of money because people
around the world stash their money here because it's a system
based on a lot of manufacturing. Not as much as there was 80
years ago. >> How much is in London? your biggest city
>> don't know the percentages. So, we have to check >> pretty
much unless you're talking about like burritos being manufactured
or whatever. I I don't think there's really >> The bigger
problem for us is not what economy we're doing. It's how we manage
the economy.
>> So, this is the exports from London. Now, I think this
is just goods, machinery and transport, chemicals,
manufactur. This is just goods. I wonder if you could switch
to services here. Total. Um I think this is this is always good.
Yeah, it's good export, man. Could you have something that compares
this to like I guess you could look at like the whole thing and
then try to say
where does where does like goods goods exports versus financial
services come in? So, it doesn't matter where the money comes
from. >> No, it does. But successive governments have dragged
us to a place where we have almost zero growth. Without growth,
you can't have a successful thriving >> That's not true.
Have you been to Japan? It's like the most successful thriving
country in the world. It has had no growth for a long not growth.
And we've gotten these lectures from the bankers for like 30
years. Japan is dying. You ever go to Japan? You There are four-year-old
girls in the subway alone. There's not one speck of litter in
all of Tokyo and it's one of the biggest. >> Ah, go west.
Go sorry. Go east. Go east, gentlemen. Let's go.
>> There just
Japan's about to collapse. I I mean, I don't know if Japan's
about to collapse, but the thing is he's like, you hear this
all this stuff from bankers. Yeah, it's cuz Japan is like Japan's
debt to GDP ratio. Like, Japan is swimming in debt eventually.
I don't know if they're going to default on it, what they're
going to do exactly.
Dr. Lamenting, you had no passport, bro. Area era. Damn. Um,
Japan, I think, has just a ton of debt. But >> 12 million.
It's an incredible society. It's the opposite of New York, London,
>> Baltimore, Detroit. It's incred. I know you've been
there, and I know you've had these naughty forbidden thoughts
like, "Wait a second. I thought we dropped a bomb on them. How
are they so great?" >> No, no, no. I like I like going
to Tokyo, but >> no growth. How' they do that with no growth?
I was assured by libertarian economics. If we had no growth,
THINGS WOULD BE BAD. WELL, LOOK AT THIS. I LIKE it in Japan,
but I wouldn't swap it for
>> right? Fair. You're you're English. That's kind of the
point, right? This is your homeland. >> I genuinely do
love London. >> I bet you do. >> When I lived in
America full time, I really missed a lot of the >> I hope
so. This is where your ancestors are from. I get it. That's the
whole point. That's the whole argument I'm making. It matters
where you're from. The culture really matters. It's not about
growth. It's not about any of this crap. It's about do I am I
>> uh I mean, we'll see. I think the population crash is
the bigger issue, right, sweatpants? like they're just not going
to have people who you can't work like 80 hour work weeks as
a 70-year-old man. Like Japan has a work ethic, the cultural
work ethic is there, but unfortunately the birth rate isn't there.
So if their whole if their entire workforce is like old as I
don't know how they like how do you maintain anything going on
there? I just don't get it. On the same page with my neighbor,
do we have something in common? Do we have the same gut instincts
about things? Those are the most important questions there. >> But
economic prosperity raises all the >> Is that has that
been true? >> It should be true. There more poverty in
London now than there was 40 years ago. >> There's more
child poverty. >> Yes, I know. >> In fact, the child
poverty rate is worse here than it is in America. >> A
lot worse. >> The general poverty. >> So, how is
this so great? Even though they have the >> general poverty
rate is actually uh lower than it is in America. But child poverty
specifically. >> Is there anything that matters other than
child poverty? I mean, not really. >> look, I'm not slagging
on I love your country. I really thought a lot about this since
I was so mean during that conversation. I was just wounded because
I feel like the destruction.
>> I was just wounded because you said Russia killed people
and that really hurt me and my >> Britain has effects on
our entire Anglo >> You actually look out and say destroyed.
>> No, this is
dude. There's just no way that he doesn't know where Anglo comes
from. I [laughter] >> again this is the rich part of town.
>> I can take you I can take you to Manchester, Birmingham,
Glasgow, Cardiff. I can take you >> How they doing? >> They're
all doing great. Much better than you think. Honestly, Tucker,
you'll walk around. You'll see the pubs packed, the restaurants
packed, the theat's packed. You'll see people having a great
time. Go out on a Friday night in London. Go to go to the Devonshire
in Soho, the best Irish pub in town, four deep in the streets,
everyone having a great time. 20,000 pints of Guinness being
sold every week. >> I could say that there are so many
things about London I really like. I've been here 3 days again
visiting relatives who genuinely feel threatened walking around.
>> No, not at all. Again, what's going to do anything?
Pakistanis are all super nice to me and the whites are all kind
>> Weren't you just talking about the stabbings? I feel
he was just talking about the stabbings.
Wait, why do you
uh you guys have like all these stabbings? There's all these
murders going on. Wait, do you feel in danger here? No, at all.
No, not at all. Not at all, guys. Not at all. >> And sad.
No, you're totally safe here, man. It's not that at all. It's
just that it's dirty. >> It's what? >> It's dirty.
Oh, >> come on. America's >> Dude, what? He's taking
so many different ts in this conversation. Now he's back to Look
at it out there. It's gross. It's disgusting. any cleaner of
>> They're dirtier. They're dirtier. And it's one of the
great tragedies. And I can't get anyone to care. Nobody cares,
>> dude. They're all dirty. They're all dirty. Bro, you
live in America. Hold on, John. No, no, no, no, no. America is
dirty, too. You know what's clean? St. Petersburg,
Moscow.
Okay, these are clean cities. These are the cleanest cities in
the world. >> I agree. So, that's >> You guys have
seen that, right? I'm pretty sure that's a part of his tour of
Russia is he goes, "I can't believe how clean it is here. Oh
my god, it's so >> To me, if I went to your bedroom right
now, I' sorry, I'm not going. I'm not going. Especially after
the whole thing. It's like I'm uncomfortable. I get it. I get
it. I get it. And you said you were so liberal, but um but if
I went to your house unannounced, I bet I would find it tidy
and clean. And I bet I would find that it's because you have
a housekeeper. I don't even know if you do, but because you care.
Because you have self-respect. That's why you shave. >> But
I agree with that point. I think the self-respect part, I totally
agree with you. We've lost that. >> So, while Tucker doesn't
quite have the charisma, yeah, I've seen him buying in Russia.
I've seen we've watched the grocery trip multiple times. Yes,
the grocery trip is like the proof that he's a total thrifter.
I want there's like an a deeper meaning to this conversation
that is instructive with regards to the Fuentes conversation
as well. Do you see how Tucker just keeps getting raped brutally
on every point because he doesn't know what he's talking about?
He's just going off of vibes. How many of you guys think that
will matter in the comments? How many of you guys think that
will matter to anybody? He has been like routed essentially on
every single point he's made. Basically, every claim he's made,
Pierce has gone, "Wait, why do you say that?" And Tucker has
like backed off of it entirely, right? Doesn't matter. He is
telling a story. He is not debating. He's not He's not really
trying to win. He's saying things that people kind of think and
then he he gets like on it and he like goes, "Oh, I don't know.
I guess I'm just asking questions." Right? It will matter. It's
a dub. Oh, you think it'll matter. I'm telling you that in this
populist moment, it's it's gonna have a diff people are going
to have a very hard time understanding
any of that. And that's like and that's Tucker doing it. Tucker
is like not playing it off well. Tucker doesn't argue well. Fuentes
is way better at any of the every part of this than he is, right?
Dub for who? This is a bad combo. Oh, this just looks good for
Tucker for for his audience for like the populace consuming the
people who want to consume populist uh populist media. This is
a huge dub for him, right? Like he's in the slur. Uh sorry, Piers
wouldn't even like engage with it. Um what else is there? Oh,
Pierce had to like own Sadi Khan. He had to own the Browns. Like
he had to be like, "No, I like my Brown mayor. I like him. I
think he did an okay job. >> That we've lost the I think
the British were legendary for our politeness, our manners, our
that has gone. We've >> Why isn't Piers calling it out?
It's Is he not aware?" No. Piers is one of these people who Well,
Piers is sharp in some cases. Piers doesn't understand. He just
thinks that Tucker's like misinformed. He doesn't understand
that Tucker's just going to keep saying this after getting raped,
right? Like Tucker literally says something, he has to back off
of it entirely. And the next time he meets anybody or the next
time he even meets Piers, he'll say the same thing again.
Pers Morgan is one of them. Well, I mean, he's standing on business
a tiny bit in this conversation and saying, "No, no, no. He's
he's one of the people who's more nationalistic than he is racist."
He is he is saying, "Uhuh. 10 of my my pies are worth 10 of you,
Tucker. My pies are way better than you, Tucker. You Tucker.
My p my British Pakis own you." That's but but then when he's
like by himself with his friends he's like man the pachy problem's
out of [__] control.
So he is one of them kind of right he's like he walks he tries
to to walk the line between both and he's like correcting Tucker
here it just doesn't matter doesn't matter man that's everything
but I totally agree with you so when you talk about the cultural
stuff that I really regret that has gone out of fashion if you
like it is things like that it's things like you know a British
person used to speak well and open doors for women and things
like now that's frowned upon right they're kind >> this
is also just wrong bro I drove across the entire United States
people open doors for me I open doors for people kind people
were Nice. I thought I was going to go to the United States and
a whole bunch of people were just going to be massive all the
time. Literally everybody I talk to in the United States is just
as nice as any Canadian is. Like I didn't run into people who
were
at least driving around and stuff like it was
like totally normal. I these people just I you I don't know how
you convince yourself of this that like your culture is going
by the wayside or something. It seems bizarre.
Screaming radical feminists have made it almost a taboo thing.
Young men in particular do not know how to behave. When I'm out
with them, I notice they don't stand up when women walk into
a room or to a table. They don't open doors for women and stuff
because they've been conditioned to think this might be toxic
masculinity and all this. That kind of stuff really worries me.
>> Do you ever wonder where it comes from? >> Um
cuz I know the answer, but I'm like, >> well, you're going
to say it's multiculturalism, but a lot of the other cultures
that have come here actually have far more politeness. >> I
agree. I agree completely. >> So that's the Yeah, >> that's
exactly my point is that the cost >> is to the invaded.
You're being invaded. You already said they're both showing up
uninvited. That's called an invasion. It's happened a lot through
history. And it's the people who are conquered, who are vanquished,
who suffer. The immigrants all seem kind of happy. It's better
than Bangalore, you know, or >> You don't feel confident.
>> Well, but you are though. I mean, people are showing
up in boats in your country. No. I don't know what to do about
that. >> Tucker is like,
h Tucker is about to wait out into the English Channel on a dinghy
and flares at boats right now. He's just on his 2015 Lawrence
Southern arc. There's nothing like this. I never expected this.
What the [__] is happening? He's just It's all the
talking points. every single one.
And I even though Lauren didn't actually flares of boats or whatever,
it's just that I feel like it's just gonna happen >> Well,
sink them. >> It's happening [laughter] again. >> Think
to put it in to put it in >> Lord Nelson put >> put
it in perspective. In the last 5 years, we've had about 200,000
people come over our southern border. In the last 5 years in
America until Donald Trump got a grip of it, you have apparently
10 million come over the southern border. Oh, more. >> Right.
So, I'm afraid there is no comparison. We have a little problem.
You had a gigantic problem. Let let me add an amen as we say
in the black church that I totally agree and that's why Britain
is so interesting because >> as we say in the black church
what right so I'm afraid there is no comparison we have a little
problem you had a gigantic >> let let me add an amen as
we say in the black church that I totally agree and
>> what he got so awkward as he as we say in the black
church as
what the [__] >> Britain is so interesting
because for >> do you not say amen in the white church
who is He talk what? What? What was >> Two reasons. One,
the people who are being invaded and replaced are the native
population. They're the Irakcoy of the British Isles. They've
been here forever. Their ancestors bones are at Stonehenge. There's
no debate about that, though. They pretended, but that's just
a fact. So eliminating indigenous populations is like kind of
a sin, I thought, but it's happening here and in Ireland and
in Scotland and in Wales. >> A B. >> Hang on. They're
not being eliminated. >> Of course they are. Look at the
birth rates. What are their birth rates? >> That's not
an elimination. >> Of course it is. Over time, it is. But
that is people taking a decision about their own lives, not having
enough children or as many as they used to have. Well, >> elimination.
No one's forcing. No one's forcing them. No one's telling the
white population of his country, you can't have more than one
child. >> Well, that's kind of the >> like realizes
that his all of these talking points eventually go to just being
a lite, right? Like fire don't fire bomb at McDonald's. On the
on the left, they say firebomb a McDonald's. On the right, it's
got to be firebomb at data center. Like literally, these are
the things that are holding you back. All of these modern comforts
are what holds you back from experiencing true life. You won't
have you don't have kids because all of your needs are taken
care of. We need to firebomb all the data centers, Amazon, all
these things. Destroy American economic dominance in the world.
I mean, it's already on its way, but destroy all of that stuff
because listen, we can't handle it. Actually, none of none of
this works. Okay? It's actually it's it's our opiate. All right?
that
the exact way that the Americas used the opium wars to to take
over and like uh subjugate China, the the app crisis, the epidemic
has destroyed the American spirit. Okay, how about NSA data?
I mean, I'm not actually advocating for it, but it's like he
just wants people to be lites. He has to understand that all
people's needs are taken care of. They they can't handle um they
can't handle like life being this easy. They're not handling
it well. They they're depressed. They're not having kids. Like
if you want to say that it's an invasion and people are, you
know, being taken over, then these are the things that are allowing
them. It's the opiate that's allowing their countries to be taken
over, right?
That is obviously the real issue. Okay. Yeah. The the true enemy
is the app storage move. Okay. That's that's the that's the final
boss. That's the final boss. Okay. as they say on the in the
racist circles, you know, when they talk about the the the ex
the something that's like the big issue. It's the app storage
is what's coming for you. Okay? That's what's taking your will
to thrive as a human.
I'm just saying. I'm just telling you, okay, that's how that's
how you have to look at it. And in which case, if they are doing
that and you are being then you have to fight back, right, Tucker?
We're at war. We're being invaded. We have to fight back, Tucker.
Point me in a direction, Tucker. or just, you know, say that
we're being invaded and never ever give any direct orders. Just
point at people who are like letting it happen and and trying
to make it happen. I'm sure that'll work out. I'm sure that worked
well for uh your one buddy when people in the left did that,
right? I'm sure that worked out really well. >> Point that,
>> but we'll pretend that we don't understand this and
we'll engage in the exact same behavior and then we'll be shocked
when something bad happens. >> The well, whatever they're
doing, I mean, they're they're certainly encou they're aggressive.
They're aggressively encouraging. Use the f word and you go to
jail. No. What is that? >> YOU CAN'T. YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHO'S IN CHARGE? YOU CAN'T CRITICIZE. You can't use the word.
>> No one's aggressively encouraging.
>> In jail for using a naughty word about gays, dude. They're
not encouraging it. What do you think that is? >> What's
wrong? >> I'll be real. Tucker literally just says he doesn't
jail for like this so he could get off. Okay, I see the cleavage
there, Tucker. I see what you're trying to get away with. Okay,
this is this is the my life my wife let me lets me watch. It's
Daily Mail articles. Okay. Thank God for the Daily Mail putting
these salicious pictures in their articles so I can actually
talk off to >> YOU'RE NOT EVEN WORRIED ABOUT GAYS, DUDE.
THEY'RE NOT ENCOURAGING IT. What do you think that is? >> What's
wrong with >> Well, if you encourage >> Wait, what?
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Tucker just said he had no problem
with >> They're certainly encou They're
>> They're aggressively encouraging. >> Use the f
word and you go to jail. No. WHAT IS THAT? IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHO'S IN CHARGE, YOU CAN'T CRITICIZE. You can't use the word.
>> No aggressively encouraging them. >> In jail for
using a naughty word about gays, dude. They're not encouraging
IT. WHAT DO YOU THINK that is? >> What's wrong with her?
>> Now Tucker will speak as though his balls have just
been stepped on, >> Well, if you encourage it and the rate
goes up, people have fewer kids. I don't know. You did you do
biology? Just to be clear, most gay people don't hit the top.
That's the point I'm making. So, if all of a sudden you have
more people being gay, which you do, >> what? No, you don't.
People don't pretend to be gay. Do >> you have the internet?
>> I don't know. I'm not saying they're >> Oh, Piers
is going to argue the left. He's going to make the left-handedness
argument, isn't he? Like like we had we just had a certain number
of gays and then it became okay for them to come out and then
that's how many gays there were. But there are always that many
gays. There's that many gays all the >> I'm [clears throat]
saying you've got way more. >> You're gay, right? >> Well,
you know, we used to say that, but >> you don't think so.
>> Well, I used to think that, but all of a >> Well,
I used to say that. Well, I used to think that. >> I think
lots of people put their hand up saying they're trans. >> Did
Did Pice just like e echo him? Did he just like mimic him? >> Listen
to Pierce mimic back the cadence the uh the the octave rise.
That's the point I'm making. So, if all of a sudden you have
more people being gay, which you do a lot. >> No, you don't.
People don't pretend to be gay. >> Do you have the internet?
>> I don't know. I'm not saying they're pretending. I'm
saying you've got way >> Yeah. You're gay, right? >> Well,
you know, we used to say that, but >> You don't think so?
we used to say that. You don't think so?
>> I I feel like he's like he's mocking him back to him.
Tucker doesn't pick up. >> I used to think that, but all
of a sudden you're >> I think lots of people putting their
hand up saying they're trans. That's a different issue. >> Oh,
it's totally different. It's not part of the continuum. It's
not like gender isn't real. I can pretend.
>> If you're gay, you're gay. >> Well, you know,
we were told that and I believed a lot of things. Do you not
believe that? >> Well, it's it's demonstrabably not true
because science tells us. >> You think they're making it
up? >> I don't think they're making it up at >> What's
your point? >> I think that you can be moved in that direction
through propaganda.
>> Well, then then how do you explain? >> Is there
anything that would make Could I make you gay?
>> How hard do you want to try? >> Not hard. I can
tell you. >> That's a spirit pier. Damn. Damn. And even
an open-minded man like you, you kind of HATE THE GAY. I MAKE
A LITTLE GAY JOKE AND YOU'RE LIKE, "OH, I'M NOT GOING TO BE GAY."
OH, NO. >> LIKE YOU'RE using a gay slur. That's >> Well,
first of all, it the context matters. As I've told you, I mean,
that's like coffee table conversation between the gays. I work
with that fox. >> So, if it's okay with them, it's okay
with me. It's just it sort of like it's sort of like racism.
Only the white >> people could be persuaded to be gay.
>> Well, I I can't believe Tucker's like trying to stand
up business and then going, "What? I don't say the N word."
Okay. If you worked at BET, it would be cool. Wait, that's not
even a good analogy. If you worked at like Fox News, somebody
who propagated like white identity stuff, and you happen to have
a few token black people who worked there and used the word,
would that make it okay for you to use the word? >> Then
why don't you explain the twofold or three-fold increase in selfidentified
in the >> I can't. They used to be repressed. It used to
be illegal in this country until the mid-60s. You literally went
to jail. So all hang on. You literally were put in a prison cell
if you were openly >> That was more here actually. You
guys did Oscar Wild. We didn't. But you also say shocking. >> Yeah,
it was terrible. you ruled the world um at the time and now you're
a joke dependent on for [laughter]
>> dude he's going to say he is literally going to gaslight
peers so hard but he basically just implied that when you guys
used to cast chemically castrate gays actually you were the world
superpower and then you stopped chemically castrating the gays
and you aren't anymore leave alone the fact that it happened
after World War II apparently he says up until the 60s apparently
they still made it criminal to be gay after World War II obviously
what happened to
uh Turing, Alan Turing, right?
And then what what's going to happen here is Pier's going to
go, "Wait, are you saying that those are those are connected?"
Like obviously you're saying that as we stop impressing gay people,
we lost our place to world superpower. And Tucker's going to
go, "Oh my god, I never said that. Are you what? What are you
talking about? Are you insane? I would never I would never say
anything like that. I would never do that."
>> And you think that's gay, so it's like a great trade.
allowing so allowing allowing [laughter] gay people to be openly
gay is is why we recommend >> blocking masculinity is the
fastest way to servitude. any Pakistani. That's why I like the
Pakistanis here. You talk to a Pakistani cab driver and you're
like, why are you gay? And they will start laughing cuz they've
watched the video and they're like, I'm not gay. I'm a man. Ask
a single Britain, why are you gay? Well, I'm not gay, but it
would be okay if I was. >> And it's like there's no masculine
self-respect at all. >> You're sounding quite homophobic.
>> I'm not afraid of gays at all. I'm just asking actually.
>> It's not what homophobic means.
>> What the is he talking about?
[laughter] You You seem really homophobic right now. No, gays
don't scare me at all. I stone them to death in my dreams. They
don't scare me. I They fil me with blood lust. Like, yeah, that's
what homophobia means, bro. [__] talking about actually
think they really exist by the sound of >> Well, they exist.
>> No, but are they real? Is this >> Dude, what why
does he he gets so serious at like the the exact moments where
I assume Piers is tapping into some like underlying belief Tucker
has that he doesn't want to acknowledge he gets really serious
like you listen Russia does people but you people too peers let's
not pretend you don't people too and how it's like I don't even
do you even think gay people exist and Tucker's like oh they
exist they exist >> genuinely sleeping with dudes all their
>> well and Are they attracted to members of the >> lesbian
thing is way overblown. >> Actually, there are a lot of
lesbians. >> How many?
>> I'm counting this conversation. >> Not recently.
>> I swear to God, I I I legitimately think Tucker watched
three episodes of America First with Nick Fentes and was like,
"Oh, this guy is really funny. He is really cool. I'm going to
do my best to imitate it." Without understanding anything Nick's
talked about over the years, without going through any of that
journey. He's like, "I just want to be transgressive and like
edgy with no point, with no like principles, not standing on
anything.
I'm just going to be edgy over and over again with no goal."
That was like his takeaway from from Nick's show was he's just
edgy for no reason. This is so great. You're going to get so
arrested after this. Be >> No one's arresting me. >> No
one's arresting me. But I'm just curious whether you think that
gay people
actually are gay or whether you think they've been somehow turned.
>> Well, for the third time, I think it's completely sincere.
>> Completely sincere. Look, the question, I'm not talking
a problem with it. I'm merely saying you get fewer children when
more people are gay. >> Please don't. >> Well, actually,
you do. >> People aren't gay. Just more people. >> You
don't get Wait, hold on. You don't get fewer. Stop. Okay. Was
it
>> didn't uh
didn't Macedonian Greeks conquer the world while being open gays
all the time? Didn't wasn't Alexander the Great like openly gay
like his generals?
seem like if if it wasn't a problem in the age where you were
actually physically like fighting people, how is it a problem
in this age?
Okay,
>> you don't understand. That was that wasn't gay. Greeks
can't be gay. Greeks, the Greek possibly under Alexander, maybe
before that. Greeks are like the gayest thing ever. Like
Greeks are the gayest mother ever.
Greeks didn't consider Macedonians Greeks. Okay. Well, the Macedonians
were mad gay. No.
Weren't the Macedonians mad? I understand Macedonia was like
a backwater compared to most of Greece. Like, it wasn't where
all of the learned people were. Obviously, they figured out warfare,
though. That's why Greco Roman idealism on the right is hilarious.
I know Alexander was by. I watched a documentary on him recently
where he's I think he was one of his generals, right? He had
like a best friend who was one of his generals. He was super
gay. Like, aren't they at least by to the point that they still
had kids? Sure. But like, realistically, if if it was like totally
accepted
in in modern western culture, if it was like totally accepted,
not weird at all, tons of people did gay, do you think that it
wouldn't be something where you have to like go fight over this
identity? Do you think more people would be comfortable appearing
on like that spectrum?
feels like but either way it's not really affecting your ability
to have kids like the ability to have kids going down in the
population like one you have people who identify as some level
of gay first of all Tucker would have to get rid of all the people
who are by there or some some level of like not purely on one
of the polls of that Kinsey scale right
which is like most of the people who would identify that way
they identify as yeah there's bias literally in the designation
right
so then okay you have so many more people identifying as I guess
is it a large enough percentage of the population to explain
the the the birth rate decline? No, it's obviously not. It's
like not even remotely close to the biggest contributor. >> 30%
of the population always like in Roman times or about 30% would
you say? >> I'm just saying. >> No, it was like this
is
more people. >> Wait, he's going to make >> you don't
get Wait, hold on. You don't get fewer. Stop. Okay. Was it like
30% of the population always like in Roman times? About 30% would
you say? >> I'm just saying. No, it was like this is >> the
falling birth rates have nothing to do with >> if you have
more if you have more gays. >> Do you have fewer children?
>> We don't have more gays. We have way more gays. >> No,
no, we have more people who >> Dude, dude, dude. Gay.
Oh, do you have more gays than in those times in like the Roman
Empire times, Roman Empire, Greor Roman era, do you have more
gays or fewer gays? You obviously have fewer gays. You still
have fewer gays, right? Okay. And they had no problem with uh
with birth rates. They had a problem with plagues, but they didn't
have a problem with birth rates. Okay.
Yes. It's not even just that, BB boys. It's not No, it's not
just a It's not even largely a function of poor prospects for
the future. It is unironically that people just have way more
fun ways to spend their time and they don't need to have kids
to propagate anything. When you used to live on a farm and you
used to have to raise cattle, you didn't want to be tending the
cattle when you were 70. So, you had tons and tons of kids cuz
you needed people to help you work on the farm. You needed people
to do [__] for you, right? This is like why people
used to have a lot of kids. You used to need kids. Now, you live
in a city, there is no reason to need the kids in the same way
anymore. You could just like live totally on your own, have all
your needs taken care of, and then you retire and you have all
your needs taken care of. It's like they they've lost their required
function.
>> It's like it's just not a requirement of society anymore.
It's dedication to the polo game. Okay. >> Who are not
afraid to say they're gay? >> They're letting their freak
flag fly >> They are actually gay, Tucker. They just haven't
been able to admit it. >> So why isn't that the case like
in Asia? >> What do you mean? >> I mean, there's
no Asian country and they're not all like putting gays in jail.
Malaysia might be. Korea's not. South Korea. Why? Why is their
self-described rate so much lower than yours? Japan same. >> Because
culturally it is not a thing. >> So it's genetic. You think
it's genetic? >> No. That's so insanely telling for Tucker
there, isn't it? Wait, why did Tucker just tie culture to genetics?
That's Dude, this guy is so insanely inconsistent. Earlier in
this thing, he kept saying Britain isn't Britain anymore. The
culture is different. You import different cultures. And and
Piers was like, "Wait, so you don't like brown people?" And Tucker's
like, "I didn't say that. Are you insane?" He's just gotten like
the He just took both extremes. He took both extreme positions
in the same conversation. Like this guy is totally joker right
now. He's got the laugh. He refuses to keep any any consistent
ideas throughout this conversation. He has flip-flopped on every
single thing he's talking about. >> It's cultural. >> No,
no. People become gay. >> The last World Cup. Let me give
you the World Cup is coming. The world soccer I'm telling you.
I'm talking about the gay thing. I'm telling you why they become
gay. WHY ARE YOU GAY? >> ONE IN FOUR countries in the last
World Cup actually uh outlaw being criminal offense. Do you think
that's right? >> I don't care. >> You should care.
>> Okay. I really care. >> You got people arrested
for using the word. That's who I feel sorry for. This chick from
Britain. >> So do right. So you feel very exercised about
that. >> She's in Great Britain. She's not in some primitive
theocy as exercised about people being arrested and putting in
prison cell for their sex if they're
>> Why do you feel as angry about that? >> Cuz it's
not my culture. It's not my country. It's not.
You just talked about how dirty London is in front of a Brit
until the point he had to like totally embarrass you in this
interview. He He thinks this isn't your culture or your country.
Shut the up. Come on. >> Well, I'm not for arresting any
I'm for arresting virgin. People should be arrested for their
sexual >> not you agree with me >> you're talk about
okay I will as a also a talk show host you're not going to get
me off my path and my path leads to this question how do people
become gay why >> they don't become gay >> what are
they born gay
>> how does that work >> they're born gay >> they
have a attraction I understand the manifestations the symptoms
>> I think probably
like I've only I've seen a couple different people discuss this
seems likely that there is a genetic component. Like there probably
is some genetic component there where you have a proclivity to
be gay and then based on like how your childhood goes you might
end up being gay
which unironically is probably why like men who get probably
end up there's like a higher incidence rate probably >> the
symptoms. >> The symptoms the symptoms the symptoms of
my >> they're born gay. >> Okay. So that means it's
not that. >> No I'm just asking how it works. So there's
a gay gene. >> Oh wait wait wait. This might have been
what Tucker was referring to before.
I see. This might have been This could have been what Tucker
was referring to before. I I misheard him >> You said you
worked with lots of gay. >> Wait, hold on. Hold on. There's
a gay >> You have this conversation with actual gay people.
>> Yeah, a lot of them say, "I got that's why I'm gay."
In fact,
>> I what I said I think is probably correct. Um,
>> a really good friend of mine who's gay, so I got that's
why. >> All gay people are gay cuz they got >> I
don't think that, but I am wondering. I don't know the answer,
but I was >> Why DO YOU KEEP SAYING THESE THINGS THAT you
don't believe? Hold on. What the [__] is your problem?
What? Why do you keep saying things?
You have to admit that either genetics or culture are a bigger
cause than one or the other of the other. Then culture is definitely
the biggest cause. If you just have a culture where you stone
gays to death, then way fewer people will come out as
They they learn to suppress those feelings very early, right?
It's the same with like,
right? If you if everybody talks about putting in a wood chipper,
it prevents any instances of from occurring. That's why you could
argue that that that paraphilia that like attraction more than
anything else deserves to be demonized because as long as it's
demonized you keep those all of those things off uh off track.
But like there's almost certainly a genetic component. There
has to be a genetic
Like that's that's just that's managing like the what do you
call it the instances the known instances. But there is some
underlying component. There are definitely people who are in
those societies who are gay and can't help being gay despite
the fact that they'd be stoned to death for it. It is definitely
both. If if you're going to be stoned to death for something
and it's just a choice, then how in the world are you then how
in the world are you going to make a decision that is going to
put your life in peril?
Like it it has to be both, right? It has to be set somehow.
If you want to say that it's like not genetic, it's like um it's
like developmental maybe, but then most developmental things
have a genetic
>> I would say the absolute majority of gay people are
gay because they are actually attracted to members of their own.
>> Again,
[laughter]
what the [__] did he just
uh did he just do a tutology? I think being gay is being gay.
I think being gay is like just being gay. I think if you're gay,
you're gay. Thank you, Piers. That's fantastic. What a great
way to
natural thing. >> You're not. Let's Let's just do science
for 30 seconds. Of course, you're right. That's the definition
of gay. I'm attracted to someone of my
>> Do I believe they're attracted to people from their
own? >> Well, obviously they have sex with them, so that's
what attract. >> So, what's the big deal? Why do you >> My
question because the self-reported incidence of it has risen.
So, we were told 30 years ago, and I I have a good memory, it's
about 10%, but the actual >> because people were being
merciful. >> Listen, listen, listen, listen. Then, but
the self-report rate was like 5%, then it's 10%, now it's like
30%. So my question is were they all born that way? 30% of a
population is born as an evolutionary matter. You tell me how
that works. How do you reproduce? >> It's still 30% of
the population >> in the United States. In a lot of places
it is 30% >> here. Still 30% >> way higher here based
on the vi part of that 30% can still produce can still produce
kids. Tucker
and he's saying 30%.
Also
it was it was higher at other points in time where where this
wasn't a problem. Wait, Moonray Murray, you understand that the
fact like if you get raped as a kid, if you get as a kid and
you become gay, that's not cultural or genetic, right? Like directly,
it's not magic. It's saying you don't know the cause. There's
like a uh what would you say?
There's like a a lot of overlapping spectra that go into making
this like to determining this outcome. And we just don't know
the exact ratios. Nobody can really say. >> What is way
higher is the number of people compared to >> where DOES
IT COME FROM 30 years ago? isn't genetic and where's the G >> 30
years ago gay people
>> I would say rape is cultural it's not it's literally
like things a thing humans do everywhere I I haven't seen a culture
that reduces
seems to be some some thing that people end up getting and then
yeah kids get
if if it was cultural then you could probably have a culture
that wipes it out seems like there isn't even a culture that
wipes it out >> I know I've heard the story we were commemorating
Stonewall the other day at my house you know I'm on board with
all of this stuff. >> Yeah, the candle light vigil. We
always do it every year. >> Yes, cultures can encourage
it. Holy Why do you say, dude, you're you're I regret that there
are so many very very dumb people here sometimes.
I >> I wish it were otherwise. >> February 9th, I
arrest my kids in this kind of mock Stonewall thing. >> What
do you do if one of your kids? >> THEY SAY, "I JUST WANT
TO BE FREE." AND THEN I UNLOCK THE HANG. >> WHAT HAPPENS
IF ONE OF WHAT happens if one of your kids says they're gay?
>> I love my kids no matter what. I love my kids no matter
what they do. They're they're my children. Would you think someone
had turned them into a gay person? Or would you accept them as
>> I'm a journalist, so I actually want to know what the
real answer is, not the propaganda answer. What would you say
to them? I don't know. That's why I'm asking you. You say people
are born. You don't want to answer because you don't have an
answer cuz you know that my answer is correct >> that they're
born that way gay. >> Then is there a gene for it? And
you know there isn't. So tell me a gene. It's it it it's the
code that determines your physical and emotional characteristics.
You have blue eyes because you have a gene for blue eyes.
>> If someone is gay, then there should be a gene that
we can isolate. It's the gay gene. And science have been looking
for the gay gene for a long time. And my question is, where is
it? I'm waiting on my gay gene. I order a gay gene and it HASN'T
ARRIVED. WAIT, WHERE'S my gay >> Doesn't mean like you
might be. >> Yeah, I'm waiting for my gay gene.
>> Dude, these are all just the oldest Twitch poll arguments.
It's like actually boring. >> If there isn't a gay gene,
then it's totally not homophobia. It's not hate. I don't want
to arrest people in Liberia or whatever the hell you're talking
>> I just want to know what is this? And no one will answer
the question. And I don't know why. It's weird, right? Why can't
we have a non emotional conversation with why are you gay? as
they say in Nigeria. Why are you gay? And no one will answer
it. Well, in Nigeria, it's a criminal offense to be gay. I don't
know. You think there aren't gay people in Nigeria? I haven't
been there in a while. >> Of course there are gay people
in >> Where does it come from? And you can't answer the
question. >> If they admit they're gay, they get put in
prison. >> That can't be right. Right. You're a gay >> Putting
someone in prison cuz he says he's gay. Of course, I'm against
that. I mean, please. >> Because he says he's an extreme
third. You guys don't bring Nigerians here, do >> There's
a lot of Nigerians here.
>> You import gay haters into your country? I thought you
were for the gays. >> NO, I'M SERIOUS. WHY WOULD YOU IMPORT?
You're just telling me that the Nigerians are bad and you said
you basically hate Nigerian. >> As you know, there are
lots of countries around the world with different laws to hear.
Different >> Why would you import them if you love the
game? Why would you import people? >> Because when they
come here, they have to abide by our laws. That's how it >> And
your values. So what are those >> No, actually you don't
have to come here with our values. You have to come here and
abide by our laws.
>> And your laws include not using the word. That's against
>> Why Why does Tucker like pretend he doesn't understand
what a liberal democracy is? You all have things that like frustrate
you and annoy you, but there is a social contract. You you vote
and you you put people into power who can change the laws, but
the laws are like the living fabric of your morality as a society
and you try to move forward with those laws like enforcing the
things that you don't want to have
You have certain rights that are like totally like that are guaranteed
by the state. Technically with like big big big majorities, they
could change some of those rights, but they don't really get
changed at this point. He just he's pretending he doesn't understand
how these things work. that you can have people who don't agree
with everything in a society that you can have an American society
that doesn't allow gay marriage and and then when they pass gay
marriage it doesn't actually necessarily change how accepted
being gay is in American culture right it's like hey actually
it became like more overwhelming that we didn't really like we
think gay people should be treated as normal and equal and should
be allowed to marry so actually you know when we vote for people
who will support gay marriage and then they pass gay marriage
not really that many people are upset we all understand that
society like that the liberal democracy is trying to minimize
it's like it's harm done to the people in general and that you
can have beliefs you can not you can you dude America allows
racists
right you don't you don't have to have the broad agreeing opinion
on everything the system is about I guess like trying to make
sure these groups can co like
why did I say I understand liberalism I just went through a really
rambling explanation it's a little bit late why would you do
that and just be offensive for the sake of >> I totally
agree with you >> I think I mostly got it right though
>> I never use that M >> it's like you're trying
to minimize the amount these groups can infringe on each other's
rights. >> Being honest, I never used that word ever. I
think it's maybe the first time I used it since the 80s, >> but
it's not a matter of custom, it's a matter of law because this
woman, mother of four, wind up in prison. >> There's like
So Tucker obviously understands all of that. This is just a performance,
but I don't know for who. I'm sure you could find a rant of Tucker
explaining the exact thing I just did more succinctly. Right.
Right. individualism only future. Like, you could probably find
a rant of him explaining it. And now he thinks that being able
to question somebody else's like enjoyment of their liberal democracy
proves that liberal democracy doesn't work. Um, I have some questions
that you might find difficult to answer, and you're going to
you're going to be really shocked about your worldview that you
think is correct.
No, there are lots of things that aren't just solved issues in
liberal democracies. Lots of things change. You're not shocking
me, Tucker. Oh. Oh, this one happens. this this format right
now happens to encourage more gay people. Okay.
Are there are
listen when when America didn't allow gay marriage,
did the birth rate still decline as like GDP rose as people moved
into cities? Like as people left rural areas, did the birth rate
start to go down as we all expect? Yes. Okay. So, it's not really
tied to being gay, is it?
obviously tied to you moving into a city and not needing kids
anymore, not having the need for kids. And then eventually that
sort of just works itself out, right? You don't need to you don't
go to New York City and live in a closet and go, I need eight
kids. I need eight kids for my job in New York City. I need eight
kids. Ain't nobody doing that, bro.
For it. So, if that's going to be the law, it's obviously like
the most important. It's so important to you that people not
insult gays in any way. you can insult straight.
>> Um, I said the the instances how likely you are in some
poll to be considered gay is likely cultural primarily because
if you stone gays to death, they're not going to identify themselves.
So, if you say how how like how the the rate of gay acceptance
in America has gone up. Well, of course, the the rate of number
of people like identifying as gone up because they're not worried
about it anymore. I just said something that was like obvious
to everyone. I didn't say that it's obviously like a cultural
incentive to be gay to have the actual attraction to the same
sex.
I said the the or at least what I meant to say maybe I didn't
say it but what I meant to say was the the proclivity or the
proclivity like actually expresses itself publicly. >> You
can insult gays as much as you like. >> Well, no, you can't
get arrested. >> I don't know that story. I'm going to
look into it. But as I said to you, I'm going to hand it to you
right here. Here it is. >> I don't think people should
be arrested for using words like that. I agree. >> There
should be social disapproval. >> You should be allowed
to be hateful under freedom of speech. >> I totally agree.
>> You know, you're not actually inciting violence against
people, which is a different thing. We should agree. If you if
I say go and Tucker Carlson and he's staying at this hotel right
now, it's a criminal offense. There's already a law on statute
in both our countries for >> So, I can tell that we were
both born in the 1960s cuz we totally agree on the underlying
human right, which is the core human right, which is the right
to conscience and self-exression, and both of us are on exactly
the same page. Where I lose you is your whole world is crumbling
around you. I'm worried that's going to happen in my country,
which is why I'm hassling you. >> My whole world's great.
In fact, it couldn't be better. >> The restaurants are
better. I totally get it. That's what matters. If I known you
in town yesterday, I'd have taken you to the Emirates Stadium
to watch my football team Arsenal beat our North London rival
41. It was the most joyous, magnificent experience imaginable.
You would have seen a multicultural crowd roaring as one. Jews,
Muslims, white, black, gay,
>> dude. Paris could totally own him from like a lot of
different angles here. Why doesn't he just go like, "Wait, Tucker,
do you not understand that we exported British culture to all
of these colonies? These are just the people from the colonies
returning home. They they felt the call of British c culture.
We absolutely wrecked a love of tea and cricket and soccer into
them and now they come back home. They come back to the the source
of all of their underlying beliefs. They naturally return. Okay,
that's that's what's happening here. These aren't these aren't
non-British people. They're people who have British culture.
Okay, they're coming back >> straight all joined as one
as Arsenal >> It's what the church used to be except they
charge you admission. I get it. I know what Brandon Circus. See,
the church used to charge you a bishop in the old uh >> we
had Martin Luther for that and we fixed that and Henry the played
along so God bless her for that. But here's the
>> No, but here's my point. If I took you to a Devonshire
for a pine of Guinness, you'd love it. Particularly Arsenal to
a massive multicultural fans, you'd love it. 60,000 people, no
trouble, no >> I'm here voluntarily. I'd love it. I just
don't want it to evaporate in. >> It's not evaporating.
Okay. Why aren't you more panicked that thousands of people thousands
>> by their own admission, the admission of the of the
British government, arrested every year for saying words, not
threats? Words. I am. >> So why doesn't someone try to
overthrow the government? I don't understand. How can they treat
you like slaves? >> Carry on down that >> what why
wouldn't I just vote for somebody else? Why would I just make
this like a single issue? Why would I just express how bad this
is? And I'm not going to vote for anybody who's willing to go
along with this or or say it's not bad. How about you just handle
it the same way everybody handles it when stuff happens in their
in their liberal democracy that they don't like. I I won't vote
for you anymore. That's literally how you do it. That's it.
>> And they will be voted out of office.
>> That's how >> is that what Winston Churchill would
say? I think Winston Churchill said, "Even if a strong man tries
to take Poland, a country we've got nothing to do. It's not even
close to here. We're going to risk the lives of our citizens
to liberate Poland.
>> Poland is closer to here than your home is to New York."
>> Yeah. Do we do we not understand at all that realistically
Winston Churchill probably had a good idea of what the German
war machine was like was turnurning out in terms of like becoming
a war machine and he realized oh these aren't for the ambition
of taking Poland he has way different ambitions
right you join this alliance you you declare war because you
want a joint effort to try to stop Germany from you
>> yes that's true that's true >> so it's all relative
so it's a tiny Lego Europe. I get it. >> If Maine got attacked,
would you expect people in New York has nothing to do with Maine
got attacked? Would you expect people in New York to help you?
>> It's the same country.
>> But you're actually [laughter] kind of a big distinction.
My country is quite >> We were part of Europe. The same
>> You were not part of I call on that. In 1940, you were
not part of Europe. Well, we [laughter] were definitely not part
of the continent of Europe. >> YOU WERE NOT ON THE CONTINENT.
If you're an island, dude, off the continent separated by a body
of water. Do you know what it's called between you and France?
It's called the English Channel. You are not part of Europe.
That is not >> I I forget. Was Germany able to attack Britain?
Did Did they not I could have sworn, Listen, maybe Tucker's understanding
of World War II history is way stronger than mine. But I could
have sworn that they have like air raid sirens that the the sounds
of like air raid sirens are almost like exclusively from the
London Blitz from like getting that that city, that continent,
sorry, that island bombed from mainland from mainland Europe
repeatedly over and over and over again.
Is there maybe a reason they didn't want to let them take France?
Could that be >> My ancestors lived here. YOU WERE YOU
WERE ENGLAND. France was considered exotic and crazy. That's
where the prostitutes and the cheese eaters lived. It's only
the brainwashing of Tony Blair and all these technocrats in convince
you European. You're way better than
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. No, no, no, no, no, no. I think
Tucker doesn't understand. Okay.
The sun never sets on the British Empire. Britain is Europe.
Britain is better than all of those people in that they had dominion
over those a ton of those people. Okay? Not literal dominion,
but but economic and figurative dominion. Okay. Yeah, sure they
were better, but they were they were the leaders of Europe. Okay.
They were absolutely the leaders of Europe.
You're an ancient Germanic.
>> Well, and the French obviously fighting back and forth.
>> Celtic people who ruled the world. Do you remember that
in your wooden ships? [laughter] Anyway, but the point is the
>> No, I'm serious. [laughter] >> Some crap.
>> Anyway, it's real with a mask from Maine, white pines.
But the point is, [laughter] dude, like, okay, hypothetically,
Tucker, hypothetically,
you gain intelligence that
Venezuela actually has been producing weapons of war for a very
long time and that they massively outmatch not just you, but
every single country. Well, actually, this doesn't really work
for the US. Somehow you you understand that they out match you.
You know that their goal is to take over the United States. Do
you wait until they get to the borders of the United States?
Do you let them take over every country on their way to the United
States? Or do you see that they've masked all of these weapons?
Do you know that they're going to attack you because you are
the real threat on that that continent or at least that part
of the world? Do you do you actually step in and help the countries?
Do you try to give them weapons? Do you try to like step in and
do something? Or do you sit there AFK while every single one
of those buffer states is consumed so that they can shell your
country, America, from Mexico, after they've taken Mexico? Which
one is it? Cuz it seems pretty obvious to me. You declare war.
Well, they were supposed to be demilitar demilitarized under
a treaty. Yeah, sure.
Dude, it's it's it's
actually crazy that that he can't understand why Britain would
like declare war. Dude, you're not even on Europe. Why would
you declare war?
Your country went to war to preserve human right. >> You
know what Britain should have done? They actually shouldn't have
declared war. They should have sat there like in a chair that
is their island. Watch all of Europe get taken over. Not done
anything. Watch Russia get totally toppled. Okay? Encouraging
the United States to stay out of it. Listen, that's we're not
a part of those. Stay out of it. Stay out of it, man. All of
the would have been killed. Okay? all of the all the uh all the
uh gypsies, all the Poles, we would have had basically all of
Slav all Slavs getting genocided too, right? They would have
taken all of Europe and and at least I guess the Russian part
of Asia, okay? They would have taken all of that and then at
the end of all of that, they would have gone, you know what,
you know what, Britain, we really respect you for staying out
of the war. We're not going to do anything to you. You get to
be your country. You get to continue to do whatever you want.
I'm not going to do
Definitely this time. Surely all that Britain did wrong was they
they failed to appease again. Surely appeasement would have worked
the next time. Surely guys, definitely 100%. >> Rights
in another country you had nothing to do with, but human rights
are evaporating in your own country and it's cool because you
have soccer games with foreigners at them and good barata. And
I'm just saying maybe something about the heroic British spirit
has been diminished with time. That's all. But there is a very
lovely quaint notion being built up in the United States driven
by people like Tommy Robinson >> Who's Tommy Robinson?
>> You know Tommy Robinson. >> He seems like a fraud
to me. >> Even Tommy Robinson.
>> Russia being toppled as a reason to intervene. Yes.
You you see a war machine that is taking over everything it touches
instantly.
Right. Obviously you start considering allies anybody who can
slow that down. Yes. Yes. Yes. Obviously, dude. If America just
started taking countries over, we all understand that the rest
of the war might just immediately declare war, right? Like if
America was just like, "Oh, it we're taking everything it. They
just start they take Canada, then they go and take like Britain,
they get halfway through Europe. It's like, oh, we might see
Russia and China suddenly acting like they're allies. We might
see basically every country on Earth. It might not matter, but
every country on Earth acting like they're allies suddenly, right?
You you you pick allies predicated on how serious the threat
is. finally a fair fight for America. Maybe
we'll see. >> His name's Steven Yaxley. It's not even his
real name. He's also convicted of multiple crimes. Thuggery fraud.
>> I don't even know anything about him, but he doesn't
seem like he's that we would call him a little stirer, right?
However, he has >> the real people here, the actual Britain.
So, >> this idea that that he's driven that we're on the
verge of some sort of civil war here. Do you feel that when you
walk >> No, because that's my point. You're so passive.
They take your human rights away and you're like, "Oh, defending
Ukraine is so important. We're so proud to have defended Poland's
territorial integrity 80 years ago." It's like,
it's funny cuz it's the same tactic that America is using in
Ukraine right now. It's like, oh, you guys are going to like
totally just run like human waves into our weapons we give them.
I guess we'll keep giving them weapons that cost us basically
nothing. It's just army surplus. Guess we'll just keep doing
that. It's like even if the US didn't agree with Ukraine as a
geopolitical rival, they might have just continued to do that.
People have done that for years and years and years. What do
you think um the Korean War and the the Vietnamese war were?
Proxy wars, right? Great. I'm so Well, sorry, not proxy, not
proxy wars for the US, but glad. >> I'm very proud of that.
I >> apparently, but it's all a kind of displacement where
you're taking your own frustrations with yourselves and your
own cowardice and sort of living in this Walter Mitti world.
Like, no, actually, we're brave. We're going to defend Ukraine.
It's like, what about defend yourselves against the monsters
>> It's like eighth on the list. Defend yourself. Defend
your human rights. They can't put you in jail for saying naughty
>> Hold on. Do you actually think America has a chance
in any war against other
Uh, I think America probably beats every other country in a war.
Sure. I mean, realistically, wars can't happen because like if
America starts taking over countries and people think they're
on like the war path totally, they might just start using nukes,
right? Then you get the ICBM, like everybody launches all their
ICBMs and everything's totally dead. But in terms of like a nukes
disabled war, I think America might be able to take every other
country at once
Um,
it would depend on how quickly they could go and take how they
could go and take like other other countries right off the bat
before those countries got entrenched and how much those countries
were willing to risk to to stay entrenched where they were. I
don't think you have ever won a war other than civil.
Um, okay. Okay.
I mean, you know, Hiroshima Nagasaki. Hiroshima Nagasaki. America's
never won a war. Hiroshima
Oh, it's like the most technologically advanced culture that
that existed outside of American hegemony. Okay.
Maji Japan. Are you serious, dude? Germany didn't have [__]
on the aircraft carriers that uh that Japan was building. Okay.
Holy [__]
>> I agree. So, march on the capital. Get >> I don't
I don't care what country he's chatting from. He just said something
so incredibly dumb.
Do you think Do you think America could really win a war? Uh
they dropped some some nukes on a country who didn't think they
could win a war. Actually, that's not true. Japan basically knew
it was the whole time, but they crazy like that. Okay. >> Out
scare them. >> Yeah. Do to them what you did. >> I
think to the >> I I've kind of stopped listening to the
end of this interview, which is fine. But have you guys ever
listened to I think it's not Sam Harris. It's somebody I associate
really closely. Um Hardcore History, Dan Carlin. You guys ever
listen to Dan Carlin's Hardcore History in Japan? Like Imperial
Japan? Holy. They're sitting in like the war room and there's
like one crazy guy who's like, "No, we have to bomb America now.
If we don't bomb America now, we won't be able to like kill everybody
in China. We won't be able to take everything we need." They
like they tried this like expand strategy. I think they basically
overperformed every single thing they did in the first year or
two of the war, including I guess the the Cenino Japan War. They
they basically overplayed everything. The only thing that stood
in their way was
all of these countries were like, "Okay, well, we have British
occupation right now." And I guess it's cool that Japan's taking
over. We like at least Asians will be dominating us and like
at least at least it'll be like an Asian occupier. We won't feel
like totally race anymore. And then Japan came in and was 100
times more racist and denigrating than the Brits were. And so
nobody um [laughter] so absolutely nobody was willing to like
really work with them. If they' just come in and been like, "Hey
Asian brothers, what's up? We're liberating you. Come join the
war." They might have actually just taken over like a ton of
if they I believe it was Indonesia they needed to get and hold
to have the the oil to be able to carry out the war themselves.
Got their war their oil totally embargoed and I think it ended
up [__] them over quite badly.
The plan was to take all that territory. They expected to lose
50% of that, but the Americans would lose the spirit to fight.
Turns out the American industrial heartland was very powerful.
Okay. The American industrial machine was unmatched, unparalleled.
They just started spamming. Dude, America, it's crazy that America
built so many like ships for the war in the Pacific that they
eventually just threw a bunch of them in an a hole in the middle
of the ocean and did did a nuke test on them. There's like, you
know what? Let's just nuke all these ships. Wouldn't that be
cool? We just nuke all these destroyers we don't need anymore.
All these like totally technologically obsolete destroyers. Let's
just nuke those. Let's see what happens.
That's crazy, right? They built so many they built so many ships
to go and kill Japan that they just were like, "Oh, nuke Japan.
Nuke Japan." They surrender. Well, we still got nukes. Let's
nuke our ships.
Damn.
the Germans opponent which you would like to do to the Russians
in the way we are a democratic society with a democratic government.
>> How was it democratic? Nobody wants if a government
overreaches and I think on free speech they've lost the plot.
If they do they will get I can guarantee you voted out of >> when
was the last time Britain's voted for millions of foreigners
to come to their country. >> Well, you don't you vote for
a >> Well, you don't ever vote for that. So, the biggest
thing that's ever happened in [laughter] your history, nobody
voted >> people flag up what their policies are going to
be. But actually what it's been is a systematic failure to control
our borders going back I would say 25 years. That's really what's
happened. >> Just all I'm saying is it doesn't seem democratic.
It doesn't seem that's what the people want at all. >> I
agree. It's now become a massive issue and the big issue actually
is because they put
>> I legitimately feel like the best explanation
unfortunately for this
is like what Fentes says. Like I understand that Fuentes is doing
that to try to like I think Fentes is doing that because it helps
him retain audience and not give audience over to Tucker and
pull Tucker's audience over, but it does seem to me like it might
actually just be that Tucker is somebody who's like an establishment
chill who's trying to establish himself on that side in the populace
wing so that he can undermine it and work within it, right? That
he can like consistently push, you know? Well, we we shouldn't
really go that far, guys. Hold on,
Gamora. The reason the US stopped oil to China was because China
was committing a genocide in in China,
right? Like it was after the Nang King. No, I'm pretty sure it
was the Cenino Chinese war where they were absolutely genociding
this country, just rolling through it doing all kinds of war
crimes, massacring everyone. I'm pretty sure that's why they
got their oil embarcode. Like they they were rolling that country
over. >> All of these so-called asylum seekers and many
of them are not. They're economic seekers who want a better life
here. I don't blame them. It's a great country to come to, but
a lot of them have been >> Oh. Oh, there's also a small
chance Porter Beller that Oh, I should have read your question
from before. So, the question I answered for Porter Beller was
he said, "I just don't understand that Tucker is trying to accomplish
or what Tucker is trying to accomplish anymore. What is the point
of anything he's done since leaving Fox? I see no throughine."
And so, I think there is the infiltration aspect. Like, he seems
to have quite strong ties to the intelligence apparatus. I I
think that's like a strong possibility. There's also a possibility
that he thinks like the Fuentes direction is where people are
going and so he's trying to like imitate that to some extent,
but he's doing a really weird job of it. It doesn't feel like
it doesn't feel natural. It feels like really bizarre to me.